want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best belief life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only tom bilyeu
as don murray once said the audience
does not turn the page because of a
hunger to applaud
[Music]
what we all have to understand is at the
end of the day the only thing that
matters is how good is your product
whether you're trying to build a company
or you're trying to be a kick-ass
employee or you're trying to be the best
parent of all time at the end of the day
the only thing that matters is getting
good the only thing that matters is
actually delivering an extraordinary
performance until you get to that point
where you can actually knock it out of
the park until you get to the point
where you can
captivate people with what you're able
to do you haven't gotten anywhere if you
want to be great if you want to leave a
legacy if you want to be remembered
you've got to focus on the acquisition
of skills you have to focus on actually
getting good that's the only thing
that's really going to capture people's
imagination and as vince lombardi said
the man on top of the mountain didn't
fall there it's so tempting to look at
people that have achieved the
extraordinary and dismiss them as being
more talented than you better than you
but what you need to see
is the simple truth
they've worked harder than you
they've earned something that you
haven't yet earned but here's the great
news that's empowering once you
understand that they've just busted ass
once you understand that they've just
put in an inhuman amount of work and
that the only thing that distinguishes
the people that are on top of the
mountain the people that have really
done something that's going to last
is that they put in the effort they work
on themselves they understand that
through discipline and effort over time
that we can get better that is the human
condition that is the thing that i find
most beautiful about being a person is
it doesn't matter if you're bad today it
doesn't matter where you start it only
matters where you're willing to go and
the price that you're willing to pay to
get there and once you buckle down and
you assure yourself and back it up with
action that you're willing to pay any
price to achieve the things that you
want to achieve
then you'll really be living a limitless
life
you'll be able to do the things that are
important
and as elon musk said
if something is important enough
you should try
even if the probable outcome is failure
and that's where most people stop and
this is the one that drives me crazy and
this is the thing about really trying to
do something with your life
yes
you might fail
yes
you might embarrass yourself you might
end up doing a face plan you might end
up wishing that you hadn't even started
but if it's important enough
even in that moment
you've got to get back up and ask
yourself honestly
where did i fail what was the skill that
i didn't have that was required of this
task and once you stop beating yourself
up once you stop turning inward with a
judgment of i'm not good enough and you
start turning inward with the judgment
of i don't have good enough skills yet
then you can do something because you
know it's only a matter of time effort
and focus between who you are today and
who you need to become to actually do
that thing so don't worry about whether
or not you're going to fail because the
only
promise that i can make you is that you
will fail
and as long as the only promise that
you're willing to make yourself is that
you won't stop
ultimately you will get to the top of
the mountain this is another part of the
the rebuilding process of somebody that
wants to completely transform who they
are um you have to change your identity
so who am i i'm i'm the smart guy and
that's how i thought of myself like i
thought of myself as being smart and
then the life slapped me around and i
realized oh wow i'm really actually not
that smart i just grew up in a small
town and so
in my small town i was smart enough i
was still never the smartest but then i
moved to la and all of a sudden [ __ ]
people smarter than me were just like
growing on trees
so i was like wow i really don't feel
smart anymore so that was like a hard
adjustment and so then putting myself
into these smaller and smaller rooms was
the solution but
i realized that i had been sort of taken
as a default value intelligence maybe it
was the family i grew up in or the
movies i watched i don't know but i just
had this default that being smart was
the thing everyone should chase
and then i realized
oh i can actually change that not
everybody values themselves for that and
so i could swap that out with something
else and
i want people to understand that
those things that are just deeply within
you that seem as if they are innate
human qualities challenge them all some
things you won't be able to change but
some things are far more malleable than
you thought and a lot of what you value
comes down to what you repeat and so
just repeating myself i'm the learner
i'm the learner i'm the learner it began
to be my identity and then rewarding
myself emotionally when i did that
repeating it rewarding repeating
rewarding then it's like through that
repetition cycle
it actually starts to be meaningful that
you're the learner and by the way i was
telling everybody i'm the learner i see
myself as a learner i'm the nurse i'm
the learner and because i was telling
people then i really felt the sense of
congruence with wanting to act like the
learner and so when you say you're going
to do something and you do it you earn
self-credibility so now i've got this
loop going i said i was a learner here i
am reading this book here i am being
willing to admit when i'm wrong seeking
out knowledge looking for disconfirming
evidence like i get to feel good about
myself for that i like the juxtaposition
of the high intensity fight or flight
sympathetic response of being in the gym
and then the parasympathetic response of
meditating and being able to rapidly
shift your state like on a physiological
level is really important so i go from
that i come out of the gym i'm huffing
and puffing i sit down and i see how
rapidly i can calm my heart rate how
rapidly i can calm my breath and i
listen to the sounds of nature so if
it's you know raining outside i listen
to rain if it's night i'll listen to the
sounds of you know like a meadow at
night
which i actually find really relaxing
and i get lost in that now the reason
that i do that is that shifts you into
what's called an alpha wave i love this
when you get into an alpha wave state
it's commonly referred to as being calm
and creative so it's not sleepy okay
that's like getting more into theta
so you feel completely alert but you
feel calm you feel creative and so parts
of your brain are talking that don't
normally talk so you get these like
really far-flung sort of creative
answers to a problem
since the whole point of this is to get
into an alpha wave state as soon as i
feel completely calm and creative
sometimes it takes five minutes
sometimes it takes 30 minutes but once i
feel calm and creative i go into
thinking where i let my mind begin to
wander onto the biggest problems that i
face in my business and in that i'll
just have these ideas and i take notes
and i go back to it so i'm still
breathing i'm still keeping my eyes
closed except when i'm taking notes and
i stay in that space and i can sometimes
elongate that for another 30 minutes so
my typical meditation's 15 to 20 and
then i'll think of tape for
10 to 40 minutes depending on like if
i'm really on a vein of something
interesting
and knowing that i'm going to be able to
do that once i get into the alpha state
i'm very i actually get into the alpha
state much faster because i'm not
thinking oh is this an idea i should
take a note on i'm just like when am i
really there yes when i feel it click in
i'm like okay cool and if i have an idea
boom then i go for it as emiliano zapata
said
i would rather die on my feet
than live on my knees
it's one of those things i think echoes
through everybody's heart but it is easy
to say and it is very hard to do and
that brings me
to the most central quote to my life
never
give in
never never never and nothing great or
small large or petty never give in
except the convictions of honor and good
sense never yield to force
never yield to the apparently
overwhelming might of the enemy
winston churchill
that to me
is the mantra that you have to say over
and over and over if you want to live on
your feet you have to understand there
are going to be times
where the might of the enemy is so
clearly superior
to the force that you have mustered in
your own soul that what they bring to
bear they are so much farther ahead they
have force that makes you want to
crumble and despair at their feet and at
that moment you have to know who you are
at that moment you have to know that
under no circumstances would you ever
feel to that that you will rise up that
you will stand before anybody not afraid
to be struck down that
you could handle
connecting to something other than the
money i was finally able to really see
and understand what it was that
motivated me and i confessed to them
that money was not my highest priority
in business my highest priority is
camaraderie i wanted to connect i wanted
to bring something of value to the
customer i wanted to think about the
customer i wanted to be myself and i
wanted to market in a way that was
inclusive and created a community
and in that community
we could do something more than just
sell products
and so we decided to sell that company
because they felt the same and they
wanted to do something based on passion
they wanted to have the energy and
excitement to see things through
and for three very different reasons we
decided to form quest nutrition now as i
mentioned i grew up in a morbidly obese
family so for me
i was never going to chase money again
and i told them that i was only going to
focus on value creation
and it had to be something that i had a
deep and personal connection to
so for me i started thinking every day
about saving my mom and my sister
my mom and my sister are both morbidly
obese and have been essentially my
entire life
and i knew that i was going to lose them
too soon if i couldn't solve the problem
of how they ended up there i wanted to
give them food that they could choose
based on taste and it happened to be
good for them
the only thing that would get me out of
bed 15 years before i'm capable of
building a billion-dollar company
the only thing that got me out of bed
was shame
so
you have to understand that people had
not misidentified me this is not a story
of someone who was born extraordinary
people just couldn't see it that i was
secretly this amazing person who was
just waiting for their opportunity to
shine this was somebody who was lazy as
had no idea what they were going to do
with their life
i had no idea how i was going to pull it
off i was absolutely terrified every
time i looked in the mirror i saw me
staring back and i knew how lazy i was i
knew how afraid i was i knew how
insecure i was i knew that at my core i
wanted people to like me and i was
terrified that they had every reason in
the world not to like me but instead of
becoming someone who was worthy of
self-respect who was worthy of their
respect
all i was trying to do was campaign i
was trying to posture i was trying to
create the illusion that i was something
because that seemed like i could do it
fast instead of just buckling down and
doing the hard-ass work of becoming
somebody new
because i had one failed
misunderstanding
i believed
that my talent
and intelligence were fixed traits
i was born a certain way
and life was about making the most of
what i'd been born with
what i did not yet understand
is the reason humans
are the ultimate apex predator
the reason that we have taken over the
globe in a way that no other species has
is because we are the ultimate
adaptation machine
darwin is often misquoted as saying it's
the strongest of the species that
survive he did not say that what he said
was it's neither the strongest of the
species that survived nor the most
intelligent but rather the most adaptive
to change
getting good at being strategic and this
is why i'm always reading business books
i'm always reading about the mind and
i'm always trying to learn about what
industry i'm going into so right now
right now boys and girls
i am
enmeshed
in the world of comics
and i'm trying to ask and answer some
very fundamental questions about why the
industry is so broken so first of all
you have to understand it well enough to
see that it is broken then second you've
got to understand it well enough that
you can actually figure out what are the
real answers to this so diving in
reading what you can finding out who are
the influencers in that space who are
the real thought leaders who's got
insight into this that's going to be
incredibly usable once you have that
then you begin compiling your own world
view of that thing but you've got to
practice that you've got to get and i
really stop mid-stream there there's a
whole universe
that goes around how you get good at
being strategic and breaking things down
i believe the greatest gift that any
great thinker can offer the world is to
take the time to write down all of their
insights they say a fool never learns a
smart man learns from his mistakes and a
wise man learns from the mistakes of
others i don't know about you guys but
for me i have spent a lot of time being
a fool i've spent a reasonable amount of
time being smart but oh man it is
precious few times when i've truly been
able to be wise and learn from someone
else but virtually every time i was able
to get some wisdom it was at the hands
of an author when people ask me who my
mentors were i always tell them it's the
authors that i've read
books contain the secrets to the
universe iron man
the movie franchise is off the charts
and what is it
at the same time that you have people
occupying wall street you have them
celebrating
one of the richest people on the planet
why
because he dresses up like a superhero
and he tries to save the world
people don't mind money
people don't mind that you want to
create a beautiful lifestyle for you and
your family they don't mind people
getting rich but they care a lot
about how you do it
they care a lot about what you do
with it once you have it
nobody likes scrooge mcduck don't ever
leak a photo of you swimming in your
money i promise it will not go well
but if you have a vision for how your
company can make the world a better
place and you use social media to allow
people to touch and be evangelized by
your brand if you're thinking how can i
make a product or a service that
actually makes the lives better of the
people that work at the company and the
people who buy the product if that's the
question that you're asking man they
will rally around you and we live in
this amazing time and you've got to take
advantage of that and it really freaks
me out when people think that we're like
either the social movement is cresting
or it's behind us it's only gaining
steam the tv is going away the mobile
phone is becoming the television like
these changes are a one way ticket to
difference
now i don't know exactly what it's going
to look like i just know it's not going
to stop and it sure isn't going to go in
reverse only in the process of gaining
mastery will you find passion so to me
passion comes out of it's kind of like
love i don't believe that love it needs
a different word unrequited love is a
very different neurological state than
reciprocal love so if you have
unrequited love to me that's something
you really like i love singing but i'm
good at it so i have unrequited love i
love singing but singing does not love
me back now i could go down the process
of gaining mastery and then i may find
that i have a real passion for it
because part of it's going to become oh
i'm gaining this skill and this skill of
singing allows me to have an emotional
impact not only on myself but on other
people i can make them feel good i can
change their mood i can tell a story
whatever it is that you want to do with
the music but when you're able to do
that and you're truly good at it and it
has the outcome that you desire then it
can become a passion but to get a
passion you've got to fight through just
ridiculous amounts of boredom fatigue
everything to truly become good enough
at it that it's a skill that has utility
i don't think people have researched
cognitive behavioral therapy nearly
enough pattern interrupting is like
everything get better at pattern
interrupting than lebron is at shooting
like you just have to be a ninja like
you've got to be so hardcore you've got
to know about how to do that with
yourself so if i have a negative thought
that's recurring i just tell myself nope
you can't think this anymore so and
every time it will come up because i
can't stop myself from it popping up
into my conscious mind but you
absolutely can control how the next
thought goes the next thought can be oh
i'm here's what i'll do with a negative
thought that's so rad i'm so glad this
negative thought appeared in my mind
because that reminds me to be grateful
for the fact that i'm friends with jay
shetty or that reminds me to be grateful
the fact i have a marriage that is so
insanely cool that like i legitimately
some days have to stop myself from just
curling up in a ball with her and just
chilling all day like that is i'm super
stoked even now jay it's so funny i had
to stop and think wait i'm going through
this list of things that i'm grateful
for what started this and i'm like oh
yeah the negative thought like that
actually just happened to me right now
so you can imagine in real life when
like you train yourself ah every time
the negative thought kicks up don't
don't sit in the emotion of the
negativity that it will bring
instead use it as a habit loop trigger
to think about something you're grateful
for and at first it feels so awkward and
it's like the negative thought just
keeps coming back but if you're diligent
and suddenly negative thoughts become a
habit trigger to gratitude to positivity
to repeating your rules about i don't
allow myself to think things that tear
me down so i'm not gonna think about
that even just saying that crowds out
that thought and telling other people
that hey this is what you're doing it is
unbelievable but this is why i'm saying
i'm literally just a patchwork of all
these like tools and techniques that
allow me to protect myself from negative
self-talk from anxiety from depression i
don't think i've ever officially been in
depression but i've been super close
enough to know the feeling of staring
into the void which i don't think is
accurate it feels like the void is
collapsing in around you and just
everything is meaningless and it is all
utterly hopeless and i've had just
enough of a glimpse of how hopeless that
is
to to get where people are in those
moments but anxiety that i've been in
the thick of
so that one i know and i've used cbt uh
cognitive behavioral therapy to do
interrupts on that um i have a very well
developed negative voice so i have had
to um use tools and techniques to stop
that i never would have become a
successful entrepreneur if i couldn't
learn to self-soothe and at one point
that was what i would have said was my
secret power that my secret power in
business was i can self-soothe faster
than anybody else all right focus on
value only value is sustainable
you want to make sure that you're
delivering value at every touch point
your customer service should deliver
value your marketing message should
deliver value your advertising in and of
itself should deliver value your ads
should be served to the people who even
though they can skip it after four
seconds they don't
that's when you're actually delivering
value people used to ask me like oh how
do you get rid of the negative voice i'm
like i don't know that you want to like
the negative voice is a powerful
reminder to practice gratitude it's it's
also a good reminder that maybe
something is wrong maybe you are doing
something wrong and you should adjust
and you should rethink i was just about
to say that sometimes your negative
voice is what protects you sometimes
very not all the time but there can be
times when it's protected in fact i'll
say it like this it it probably does
protect you all of the time but
it's
so repetitive
that you touched this issue and now
we're into the 9 000 replay of this
that's where it becomes stupid and so
the one thing yep cool got it i do need
to work on that you're absolutely right
um
and then just letting it go right and
not clinging on to it not beating
yourself up over it and all that stuff
but yeah it has a use which is why it's
so powerfully with us i love inspiration
and motivation but it is the
neurological equivalent of candy it's
rad it has its place
but everyone because those just happen
to be fleeting neurological states yeah
you you just have to find something
that's way more grounded you need a
mission you need a grand why you need to
know what it is and and this is not a
discovery it's a thing you decide i
decided now because i tell it as a story
people think oh it was unavoidable he
meets this kid rashaan and that coupled
with all the people that he worked with
the quest it's sort of inevitable that
he decides that he's going to
build impact theory and try to change
culture to give everyone an empowering
mindset yeah well literally a year
before i decided to found impact theory
my mission in life was to end metabolic
disease so it's like you decide and then
you point yourself at something nothing
is ever going to feel right like this is
what i was put on earth to do it won't
feel that way until about a year or two
years after you've been saying that's
what you're going to do that that's what
you're committed to and actually acting
in accordance with it and then you'll be
like yeah this actually is my mission be
transparent
it's a new world order man when i was
coming up you didn't be transparent
you put a marketing message out you spun
that
like you tried to be as close to the
truth as you could
but you didn't worry about transparency
but these days
consumers expect transparency they want
to know who you are they want to know
what you're doing they want to know what
it means to support you because it's not
enough that your product is good
they want to know that your company
stands for something
but it's also incredibly meaningful to
your employees
you want to keep top quality talent
around for a long time
you want to make sure
that they know what's going on in the
company for the person who's stuck for
the guy or gal who's in the cubicle
who's hates their job is in a
dysfunctional relationship is in debt
whatever the case may be
desperately wants a way out a way
forward a lifeline
where does that process begin for you
like what is the advice that you give
that person
so it begins with believing or
acknowledging that humans are the
ultimate adaptation machine so the the
thing that has made us the apex predator
is not that we're stronger um it's not
even that we're smarter in fact the the
quote often attributed to darwin is that
oh it's the survival of the fittest he
actually didn't say that
what he did say was it's not the
strongest of the species that survived
nor the most intelligent but rather the
most adaptive to change now the reason
that humans are the apex of all apexes
is because we are the most adaptive
species to change so if you know that
then it becomes infinitely less
important who you are today
and what matters is who do you want to
become and what price and the price
being the time and energy that you're
going to put into acquiring the skills
to become that person so imagine the
person that you want to be how would
they act and then start acting like that
if the person that you want to be would
leave their job and
you know regardless of whether they had
a safety net burn the ships and go after
something new then that's what you
should do if the person that you want to
be would start working nights and
weekends because they very much value
having a stable income that they can
provide for their family or themselves
whatever
but are going to be disciplined and
spend nights and weekends to get the
skill set to go be more valuable
somewhere else or to start their own
company whatever then do that how do you
process issues how do you do you have a
system on what you go through something
happens something comes up
in your brain is there a step process
you go through yes what is it starts
with the goal so what is my goal
well first it starts with clearing the
emotion because probably whatever i was
told just had some emotion i recentered
myself the thing that i probably repeat
to myself the most is you can do
anything you set your mind to on a long
enough timeline so i know i can learn
anything so if the thing that hits me is
overwhelming because i'm scared i don't
know how to do it you can do anything
you set your mind to so at the end of
this thinking through is going to be the
question are you willing to set your
mind to it or not
and then i identify okay what's my goal
does this move me towards my goal yes or
no i think through the process of has
somebody done it is there already a
well-laid path from where i'm at to
actually completing this which is how i
decided that we were going to take on
disney because looking at the only
studio ever in the history of time to be
disciplined enough to only tell one kind
of story from a thousand different
angles so much so that they gave birth
to americana
is disney no other studio everyone else
is all over the map if i say i'm gonna
go see a sony movie or a paramount movie
you don't know anything about it but if
i say i'm going to go see a disney movie
you already know something so their name
brand means something so i could see oh
there's a path from where i'm at to the
impact that i want to have so i throw
that out just as a reminder of the path
that i'm walking more than i have some
particular obsession with disney
fascinating and by the way in your in
your mind do you see it already that
vision becoming a reality no question no
question
no question about it for sure and look i
have days of where i'm like how am i
actually going to do this but then you
come back to you can learn anything you
set your mind to so just keep marching
forward your mind begins to lay down
patterns over time neurons that fire
together wire together so if you let's
say you want to do public speaking and
you get nervous every time you're about
to public speak then you begin to
develop this pavlovian response of
anxiety as you go to speak but you could
interrupt that pattern you could find
ways whether it's taking a much more
confident posture which there's all
kinds of amazing research on how just
your posture changing your posture
creates a different internal reality
going back to your creating the state
that you're in if you're sitting like
this and you're allowing your face to
take on this really droopy sad posture
it's very different what you feel
is very different than if you take an
open confident posture if you hold your
face in a very optimistic upbeat i dare
you try to be really pissed off and
laugh out loud it just doesn't work
understanding that all of that stuff is
intentionality at play it's
you
choosing what you think it's you
choosing what you believe it's you
choosing what you feel and all of that
stuff has a material impact on the world
around you take meditation
i eschewed meditation for years i
thought it was the dumbest thing in the
world i tried it didn't make any sense
to me until someone explained what i was
really doing was gaining control over my
autonomic nervous system because right
now so much of your life happens in the
subconscious the vast majority of the
data that your brain processes is done
subconscious in fact the conscious mind
is the last person to know if you guys
have seen david eagleman and what he
talks about how there's all this
neurological activity going on things
that are known things that are discarded
things that are moved towards and the
last person to know about it is your
conscious mind despite the fact that
he's going to take credit for all of it
your conscious mind is actually the last
to know so being able to take control of
the autonomic nervous system is so
powerful
it's going to allow you to center
yourself before giving a speech it's
going to allow you to calm yourself
before taking a test it's going to allow
you to perform at a higher level take
the navy seals the navy seals
teach breathing exercises the navy seals
teach meditative practices because when
you get into a combat situation and
things are flying and moving really fast
and it is literally a life or death
situation you've got to learn to calm
your autonomic nervous system and if you
can't do that if you can't lower your
rate of breathing if you can't calm your
heart rate if you can't push the blood
back into your prefrontal cortex so that
you can make
the right decisions and quickly
you're screwed so
learning that this is all intention
learning that your brain is housed in a
shell and it never sees the light of day
it never actually encounters sound it
encounters electrical and chemical
signals and from that it paints the best
version of reality that it can but it
isn't the total reality and it isn't
objective
once you accept that once you get that
there's even a crack in that door of
subjectivity and that you can control
that subjectivity then all of a sudden
your beliefs become things to control
and manipulate to move and construct
around something that serves you
list the beliefs that you have about
yourself and put them in two different
sides on one side i want you to list the
things that empower you and move you
forward on the other side i want you to
list the things that demotivate or
demean you and move you away from your
goals and then i want you to look at the
balance my guess is most of you have
more beliefs about yourself that are
detrimental that make you less of who
you are than you have on the positive
side of things that make you bigger that
make you more confident that give you
the courage and the audacity to move
forward once you realize both of those
are fake
both of those are merely a
representation that your mind has chosen
to give you and they're not objectively
true then you can realize hey i can
change these i can choose to believe
things that empower me i can choose to
ignore things that move me backwards or
change them
but it's all a construct get control of
your mind it's so powerful in fact the
most powerful form of mind control
is control over one's own mind you were
first of all never going to be right all
the time yet you have to move forward as
if you are right you have to come to a
conclusion about what is the most sure
path to your goal and be marching down
that path
this is advanced class [ __ ] but you also
have to be able to go am i right
so at the same time you're racing
forward as
fast as you can you've got to
occasionally check yourself and say is
this actually working is there data that
i can look at what empirical evidence do
i have that i'm actually going in the
right direction now you want to know
where i spend the vast majority of my
time
it's in that if i'm not actively
executing and even sometimes when i am
actively executing i am i'm doing these
little checks what's the data what data
points can i look at so not like it
feels right not i want to do it is there
data that i can look at that tells me
i'm either going in the right direction
or i'm not so i have that feeling all
the time i'm trying actively to delude
myself since the people that are most
delusional are the happiest i'm trying
to delude myself to make sure that i'm
going and going with enthusiasm i'm
trying to delude myself that despite the
fact that i know
next to nothing of what i'm going to
ultimately need to know in order to
succeed that i keep going that is
fundamental and critical and then whilst
i'm deluding myself i'm checking to make
sure that that delusion never gets out
of hand that i'm still grounded in
reality that i'm still checking myself
against
data and all of those things are going
to be what allow you to keep this from
spilling over into something that's
counterproductive because there is a
level of delusion that's useful and then
there's a level of delusion that is
it's going to break you down it's going
to take you in the wrong direction so
you've really got to check yourself
against that now getting good at that is
not easy but leaning on data data data
data what is the external world telling
you
and not being afraid to see that the
external world is telling you that
you're going in the wrong direction and
then being able to pivot i own a
nutrition company but i am not a thought
leader
i'm an influencer
i have a thought leader that i trust
that i listen to happens to be my
business partner
but i'm the one that then translates
that for the masses
so when you're trying to build a
community the person you're looking for
at the top you want to make sure the
thought leaders believe in your product
so you're going to send it to them
you're going to explain it to them
you're going to make sure that your
product is real because they will smell
be us bs a mile away now if they're into
it and then you go after the influencers
who will then ask the thought leaders
what they think thought leaders will
give it the green light the influencers
then will begin telling the masses
influencers in my world are people with
six-pack abs they're the guy at the gym
they're the girl at the beach in the
bikini people that other people walk up
to and say whoa what did you do to get
in such great shape and we wanted to
make sure their answer was i ate a quest
bar
and that was how we grew the business
and we wrote individualized letters to a
bunch of influencers and a bunch of
thought leaders saying hey we know who
you are which by the way we were very
sincere it was all real we know who you
are
we think this product brings value to
you and the people that follow you and
we just want you to talk about it if you
hate it tell people you hate it and if
you love it tell them you love it
all right you want to find your thousand
screaming fans
the thousand screaming fans are those
influencers that are gonna get attention
for you
identifying them most people think of
these people as getting to your thousand
screaming fans for you but what they
should be thinking about is this now i'm
sure most of you knew the people in the
previous slide i'm sure most of you
don't know any of the people in this
slide but this woman here anybody know
who jenna marbles is
show of hands i hear a couple yeses
there we go all right jenna marbles has
a daily reach of 20 million people
that's bigger than the biggest show on
tv that's crazy
this is the world of social
it seems hidden to most people over 35
but it is in plain sight
these are the people that you're going
to be going after jenna marbles we sent
her
dogs sweatshirts
and a whole stack of our product now why
did we send her dog sweatshirts because
their dogs are little chihuahuas they're
skinny as hell and they always look cold
so we had some custom-made sweatshirts
sent to her she loved them so much she
started promoting
the bars and showing people what we had
sent her and thanking us now no money
exchanged hands
it was just us doing something that she
would think was cool that her followers
would think was cool and we got to tap
into that reach that's the power of
social
i won't belabor these points social is
still despite what you may think largely
free it's real-time connection raw
feedback think 30 years ago how much you
would have paid for real-time feedback
from your actual customers written right
to you telling you if they think you're
amazing or a jerk or whatever they may
think is absolutely incredible and they
want you to respond and win them back
over it is amazing it lets you test
things rapidly which is amazing and it
lets you build a community very rapidly
so you need something else that's going
to get you off the hook and it has to be
that core belief system in your life a
belief system that you put in place when
you were emotionally sober and you said
to yourself i'm making a pledge i do and
believe that which moves me towards my
goals period
not when it's convenient
always
and that becomes a guiding light in my
life if the guiding light in your life
is that you only do and believe that
which moves you towards your goals
when you get into that loop of beating
yourself up and thinking that you're
worthless or that you're never gonna
make it
remember that
that belief does not serve you
and you don't do things that don't serve
you
and not to rat anybody out but do you
know how many people just today
have broke down in tears in front of me
and the punch line is always the same
they don't think they're going to make
it
they become convinced they're more lost
than other people
they're less capable than other people
that while other people are going to
have these beautiful lives not them
here's the irony
everyone feels that way
everyone goes through moments of doubt
and despair
so you need something to protect your
mindset against that loop because it
will chip away at you
and the belief is
very simple
you don't do things that don't serve you
people have got to reject this notion
that they have to be protected from the
outside and putting all their time and
energy into that be the change you want
to see in the world if you want to see
people strong enough to withhold a
better weight then don't worry about
trying to fix systems just [ __ ] get
tough watch how people respond to you
watch out your kids look up to you watch
how your family members look up to you
watch how people turn to you and want
help people we have an innate desire to
get strong we don't have an innate
desire to have something else protect us
all of us if two buttons man one of them
is you're such a badass nothing can ever
hurt you you get it you know how to
figure it out you fight your way out of
anything or
a magic fairy will follow behind you and
just waft things away
the terrifying thing is
this button the magic fairy is going to
get pressed a lot more than this button
but this button no one dies of suicide
with this button this button mother
race towards suicide and depression and
if you want to know why we're having a
pandemic of that and i don't want to
cheapen it because it's largely
microbiome and there's all kinds of
health things that are going on i'm not
taking that away but on the mental side
of what's driving a lot of people not
believing in that is we're just
culturally reinforcing that like we're
stuck we're trapped there's nothing we
can do that people don't understand the
fulfillment has to be earned you can't
tell someone to just love themselves you
have to tell them how they earn
self-respect you have to tell them that
doing hard
that you don't want to do and doing it
anyway that's exactly how you gain
self-worth you can't just tell someone
to feel worthy
man i want you more than the next person
like i
i spend an inordinate amount of my time
every week talking to a camera
trying to help people to touch their
lives for real like my wife and i made
so much money we could have actually
bought an island and retired and never
worked again
but that's not what i want like i want
that fulfillment i want to do hard i
want to touch people's lives i want to
lift them up i actually want to
transform and change them the single
most important part in learning to be
honest with yourself is to accept that
you must have self-esteem
and the problem is most people build
their self-esteem around something
stupid so most people build their
self-esteem around being right being
good being smart being worthy and they
see all of those as permanent traits and
so anything that challenges them being
smart which is my big one oh god even to
this day if i really want to get into a
bad place i'll just go hang around
people that are just legitimately
smarter than me and then focus on how
cool being smart is now i can be around
them when i value myself for being the
learner but the second i let myself slip
into just wanting to be cool for being
smart then being around those people is
like getting kicked in the face it sucks
man and so i had this i went through
this phase in my life that i call the
king of remedial jobs phase and i
wanted so this is post film school post
like realizing that i don't have talent
i just need to be smart man i just need
to build myself back up by being smart
and so i would apply for jobs like i
worked i sold video games retail um and
i sold insurance door-to-door i did
anything that i could where i knew that
the person interviewing me at some point
during the interview was gonna say why
are you applying for this job like
you're too smart for this and be like
i'm right where i need to be which is
crazy and sad but absolutely true and so
i did that for a couple years and in
that phase it was i just didn't want my
intelligence to be challenged so flash
forward now i'm working with these two
entrepreneurs they hire me as a
copywriter i'm in an entrepreneurial
environment for the first time and
they're
clearly smarter than me that that isn't
even up for debate and i'm
arguing with them for this idea because
i needed to win i just i couldn't take
another time where it's like they're
smarter than me they're smarter than me
so i was like all right i'm gonna win on
this idea and somewhere in the argument
i realized i was wrong and there was a
voice in my head screaming you're wrong
dude you are wrong you know you're wrong
shut up like stop pushing for this what
are you doing and i kept going and i
finally like whittled them down and they
finally just gave up and so they said
yep we'll do it your way fine whatever
and
right then and there's the one time in
my life that was truly a lightning rod
moment where my life can be divided
before and after
and that moment was realizing that i was
telling everybody that i wanted to get
rich
but the way i was acting was like i just
wanted to feel smart
and i thought hey no judgment i'm
totally cool whichever it is like we can
craft a life where that will be
wonderful so
if what you really want is to just be
smart and to feel smart all the time you
have to quit you've got to get out of
this environment because they make you
feel stupid all the time and that's not
a great place to be feeling badly about
yourself all the time for any reason
even if it's self-inflicted it's not a
bad scenario or it's not a good scenario
you've got to get out of it so i was
like okay so that's option one get out
of this scenario go back to being the
king of remedial jobs
or if you actually want to get rich
start acting in accordance with it start
making decisions based on that and so i
was like okay well i'm gonna have to
give up my self-esteem i'm gonna have to
like stop worrying about feeling good
about myself and i was like oh
that is clearly a losing proposition
there is no way to come in and feel
horrible every day and think that i will
have the energy to see this through so i
was like god what else could i do i was
like well i guess i could build my
self-esteem around something that
is sort of impervious to being around
people that are smarter than me and what
would that be being the learner and i
thought okay well i could choose to do
that i could choose to build my
self-esteem around being
not
right but finding the right answer not
being smart but working hard to learn
and so that became just like the core of
my existence i decided in that moment
i'm going to start valuing myself for
how rapidly i can admit when i'm wrong
how much i learn how much time and
energy i put into learning and once i
switch that and i switch my identity and
my behaviors around to being the learner
then all of a sudden everything changed
and that's when i went on hockey stick
growth because all of a sudden if we
were arguing and i realized you were
right i'd be like dude he's right you're
totally right i see it oh my god thank
you so much and so i started earning a
reputation i never just backed into a
corner i never argued for something just
because it was my idea i was
legitimately on the hunt to find the
right answer and so now i'm getting the
internal feedback of hey you said that
you were going to always focus on being
the learner you're doing it you said
you'd always admit when you're wrong and
i would try to shorten that timeline
down so i wasn't like taking an hour to
finally admit it or even three minutes
that i was trying to get to it like dude
if i realized i was wrong three seconds
30 seconds max like i'm you know just
finally saying it look you're totally
right i'm with you yep i see it and then
the world was like whoa working with
this guy is awesome he's not trying to
take credit for other people's ideas he
will change on what he was saying in a
heartbeat when he you know he fights for
what he believes in but the second you
can convince him he's convinced and then
he moves on it just became a really
awesome environment so that was hugely
transformative but it forces you to
constantly be on the lookout for where
am i wrong so my wife and i had tried to
start our first business well we did
start a first business and it made money
but i made very little money it was a
photography business
and
that gave me that entrepreneurial drive
like i wanted to do it i had a little
tinge of it when i was selling for
prepaid legal
and then really felt it when i was doing
the photography but i just looked at the
dollars and i'm like this never goes
anywhere i can never make enough money i
didn't have the words to explain it but
it was because i was time for money and
you can't break the wealth equation if
you're dealing in time for money so
i was like all right i want something
more but i don't know what that more is
and then two of my um
two of the people that came through and
saw me speaking about filmmaking uh were
these two entrepreneurs and they were
the two things i'd always promised
myself as a kid that i would have is
that one day i would have six pack abs
and one day i would be rich those were
my two promises and that really guided
my life in like a very sincere and
intense way for a long time
and they come across my path not only
are they wildly successful in business
but they're yolked
and i was like whoa so these guys are
like yo we're gonna work together
someday and people would tell me that
all the time and i was like yeah yeah
yeah and not really believed it and they
called and said look we're starting this
new company and why don't you come be a
copywriter we settle for employees but
we're always looking for partners
and you can have any role in this
company that you want you just have to
become the right person for that role
and that's really their pitch yeah and i
saw him make that pitch to everybody
dozens of people well dozens and nobody
did anything with it and i was like what
do people not see like what they're
offering and everyone was telling me
they're full of dude like can you not
see like these guys are just trying to
take advantage of you and i thought even
if they are like what do i have to lose
exactly like as long as my payroll
checks are clearing and they're not
doing anything unethical i don't quite
understand the risk so everyone was like
freaking out telling me that i shouldn't
do it
and i was just like oh wow this seems
too like it's too self-evident to me
that i could always go back to teaching
and that i might as well try this and if
it sucks then i'll go back what's this
fascination you have with the matrix
movie i
am fresh out of film school about a year
out of film school so the matrix came
out in 99 i graduated in 98 so i'm i'm
hopelessly lost at this point
and i go to a comic convention love
comic books and i come around the corner
at this divy little comic um convention
like if you're thinking san diego
comic-con this was not that this was
like a diving little thing and i come
around the corner and there is um
carrianne moss
um keanu reeves joe pantalioni joe
silver the producer like just this whole
panel of people i'm like what and so
this is like i mean film is the center
of my life at this point i'm like i
can't believe these people are here i
had no idea and they're like hey we're
handing out tickets to the premiere
tonight you can see it on the back lot
of warner brothers no way i was like oh
my god it's incredible so i go
uh and i'm waiting in line and as i'm
waiting in line literally just like in
the back alley of warner brothers the
doors burst open people come out
screaming and i was like what is going
on and so i plug my ears because i don't
want to hear if they're gonna give
spoilers and and they all go off but i
could tell something special yeah they
were into this thing
go in sit down we're watching it and you
know that moment where um
agent smith comes up to the cops very
beginning in the movie and he said i
told you to wait until we got here and
he said oh we can handle one little girl
no officer your men are already dead and
they cut up too she jumps up and in that
moment the entire audience all at once
screams ah like they just go nuts yeah
and i was like that has never happened
to me before ever in a movie there was
just something so captivating and then
ultimately the matrix is the perfect
metaphor for the human experience it is
about a guy who from the day he shows up
has the same abilities as the day at the
end but once he learns to believe in
himself then he can actually do more
even though he had the same potential
he's able to do more at the end and i
was like that's life like you've got
this potential but if you don't believe
in yourself you're never going to put in
the work to actuate it i'm not afraid to
be audacious because i know that you're
never going to exceed what you're aiming
at so you're only your
hope is to hit some percentage of what
you're aiming at so i might as well
dream massive and one it excites me and
then two i'm not afraid of the failure
so once you have that like oh it's
exciting for me to dream big and i'm
hyper conscious of you break it down in
small pieces like i'm i'm not worried
about building theme parks and all that
stuff right now what i'm doing right now
today is make a good comic put out a
good interview show that's it that's
what my life consists of stay in
business be profitable like those are
the things that i think about so i keep
my
you know my goals my immediate term
goals very manageable but i make sure
that they're feeding naturally into the
grand vision but i don't get scared or
lost and thinking oh my god i have to do
all that nope right now today i need to
read a script i need to make sure it's
okay i need to authorize it to be drawn
that's it that's today and as long as
you're able to focus on that and get
good at that and then just always push
yourself to make your skill set better
and better and better as long as it's
leading towards that thing and you have
clarity on where you're trying to go so
you make sure the skills you're
acquiring will actually lead you there
you'd be fine that quest went so fast
wasn't just because we had done
something to our minds and gotten to the
point we were so angry that we were
going to push us forward no matter what
it was understanding the timing of the
marketplace and the technologies that
were emerging and the technology that
was emerging in 2009 when we first
started thinking about the company
everybody thought facebook was a joke
everybody thought it was a huge
distraction and what we understood was
it was just a megaphone
we didn't pass judgment on it
we just knew it was a megaphone
and it was a free megaphone
and if we could give them reason to say
something good within a couple of
minutes of an interaction with us they
could have a global audience and tell
people about that
so we saw that the timing was right
there and we also understood that people
want to have impact i believe
the very meaning of life
is to find out how many skills you can
acquire that have utility
and then put that utility to the test in
service of someone else it's what the
ancient greeks call techne
i've worked my ass off for this set of
skills they are unique to me
and they help other people and in being
able to help other people with something
that i worked very hard for i feel good
about myself
and i will make you guys one promise
right here today the game you're playing
please listen to this
so that you don't end up wasting years
of your life like i did mine
the game that you're playing is not
success
the game you're playing is not money
the game that you're playing
is brain chemistry
it's about fulfillment
the only thing ultimately that's ever
going to matter in your life
is how you feel about yourself
when you're by yourself my father-in-law
once gave me this advice
he was the first person i met that had
really been successful and he said
what you want to do
is know more about any situation than
anyone else in the world
and i actually remember what i said to
him i said yeah my boss doesn't really
think like that i have since apologized
to my father-in-law for giving me such
an amazing piece of information and me
doing nothing with it for like six years
but once i understood that the only path
to excellence is to truly become an
expert the only path to excellence is to
actually get good at something
these days in a hyper-connected world
where within minutes of an interaction
with you your product whatever someone
can have a global audience and tell
people what they think that product
better be awesome
but the great news is the world's been
democratized now
you no longer have to have
150 million dollar ad budget in order to
cut through the clutter in our first
eight months we were profitable at month
six in our first eight months we didn't
invest more than ten thousand dollars
because we had a product that actually
delivered value
our marketing message delivered value
and if you focus on that if you focus on
making something that's better than what
other people are doing now you really
can cut through the noise very very
quickly
and you gotta grind baby grind
that was me for almost two years
people see where the company's gotten
they see me up giving speeches but what
they don't see is that in the middle of
the night my hands used to wake me up
cramping closed
because all day i was making protein
bars and in the very beginning we were
running the technology company during
the day and then going and making
protein bars by hand at night with
rolling pins and handheld blades that we
cut the bars and then wrapped them three
at a time we wrapped them three at a
time we would make 1200 bars i think
nine of us made 1200 bars over a six or
seven hour period now in a day we make
1.5 million
but that's where it starts it starts
with a willingness
to persist
long after it's boring it starts with
the ability to focus
on your end customer long after you're
exhausted it starts with the ability to
think about those people that you really
want to serve when you're scared and
have no idea how you're going to pull it
off
but you chose to believe
that you could do it you chose to
believe that and because you chose to
believe that you were able to achieve
excellence this is the central mantra of
my life
it doesn't matter who you are today
it really doesn't so if you feel like
you're incapable of something maybe you
are today
but just because you're incapable of
something today doesn't mean that you're
not capable of learning that thing so
it's not about who you are today
it's about who you want to become
and the price you're willing to pay to
get there
and i promise you
the day that you're willing to pay any
price
you'll achieve what you want to achieve
i knew exactly what i wanted i had my
why i had my goal and it was very
specific and this is the thing about
goals they have to be incredibly
specific and my goal was to end
metabolic disease
not sell a lot of protein bars that was
not the goal i wanted to end metabolic
disease and that informed every choice
that we made as entrepreneurs every time
that we had to answer a hard question
one that might impact profitability or
how late we were going to have to work
or what we were going to have to do and
it almost always was difficult including
by the way we had to become our own
manufacturers which we did not want to
do
we wanted to outsource it we just wanted
to be marketers
but nobody would make the bar for us
or they would but they said that we had
to add sugar to it and we asked a simple
question will that help end metabolic
disease yes or no if yes we'll do it if
no we won't and it wouldn't so we didn't
it starts with that specific goal
and then because i had my why
my hands cramping closed in the face of
doing something to save my mom and my
sister it was not a hard choice in fact
i wouldn't have been able to look myself
in the eye and say i was not able to
help them because it was hurting my
hands
right it sounds ridiculous when you say
it like that but most people don't have
a personal tie to what they're doing
mother teresa has an amazing quote no
one will act for the many
but people will act for the one
[Music]
and so as you guys go into your jobs and
you think about what you're trying to do
find a way to stop making it a job find
a way to make it a calling a vocation
something that really meets that why
your desire to connect or do something
great for people what it's really going
to take for you to get to that next
level is to understand that the person
that you are
has gotten you as far as is ever going
to get you
so you've got to become a new person
you literally have to adapt
now the great news is like we talked in
my first talk that is what humans are
wired to do
humans are the ultimate adaptation
machine the reason that we are the only
species that you can find in every
corner of the globe at one point james
cameron was literally at the bottom of
the marianas trench we have sent human
beings to the moon
we are going to send human beings to
mars
and the reason we're going to be able to
do that is we can adapt to our
surroundings
there was a woman who swam the bearing
straight
really think about this the bearing
straight is the space between russia and
alaska so you can imagine it's not quite
a swim in the bahamas
to make the swim
she had to change
her fat
from what's known as white adipose
tissue
to brown fat
brown fat is more thermogenic so it
actually kicks off heat
to do that
for over a year she had to expose
herself routinely to cold temperatures
sleeping in the winters in alaska with
the window open
but in doing that she actually put her
body through an adaptation response her
body got the message adapt or die so it
adapted and when you're willing to put
yourself under those kinds of stresses
to become that new thing you want to
become to be the new person that you
want to be to go farther than anyone you
know has ever gone to be the goat it is
possible
but it demands a price
it demands a price
and what this weekend is about it's
about you deciding for
where do you want to go
and what price are you willing to pay to
get there
there's no right answer
there's no wrong answer
there's just
clarity there's just clarity
don't judge yourself if you don't want
to play on a world stage
don't judge yourself if you're not
willing to pay an extraordinary price
just get the clarity of what you want
and what you need to do to get there
when you do that
then you're going to be able to
construct a narrative about who you are
if somebody's giving you advice about
something that they have not done in
their own life then they have basically
a zero believability score and somebody
who has a zero believability score
shouldn't be pushing their idea like
they know something they should be
asking a lot of questions now when
you're talking to somebody that's done
ray dalio saying is three times or more
if they've successfully done something
three times or more than they have
believability in that area so you want
to find people that have believability
that really know what they're talking
about
and
then you should listen you should ask a
lot of questions you should really come
to understand it if they haven't done
that they may still have amazing ideas
but what you need because the
um you know sometimes a novice has
really fresh insights because they're
just not stuck in the dogmatic ways of
thinking that experts usually get into
but you need to be thinking about it
differently so rather than listening to
their conclusions you should be trying
to understand their methodology how did
they get there what is their process
their reasoning for making the statement
that they're making now if their
reasoning is sound then their conclusion
may very well be worthwhile but you have
to understand their reasoning so one of
those two things so either they are an
expert in that area and thusly you
should listen or they are not and you
should only be thinking about what their
process was to get to that conclusion
then you have to be able to derive your
own assessment as to whether or not you
should listen to them there's not going
to be anything more empirical than that
social media is going to allow you to
have real meaningful relationships with
your customers
i will tell you one very fast in the
very early days of quest when all of us
had to go out and actually make the bars
i'm out making bars our chief marketing
officers out making bars like
everybody's out there there would be
periods of time where we wouldn't
respond to somebody on facebook but this
one woman started responding
and we thought wow that's so weird like
is did somebody create a fake account
like is that one of you guys everyone's
like no man we didn't do it that's a
real person and she would tell people
like oh don't worry i'm sure they'll get
back to you quickly they're really great
company and we were so and this is like
early 2010 we're like what is happening
and so we reached out and said hey we
want to put you on payroll she's like i
don't want to be on payroll
and i'm like whoa okay now i'm getting
freaked out like what do you want and
she was like i just want you to continue
to deliver a service i'm a nutritionist
and i use your bars with a lot of people
i just want to make sure that you're
around so we developed this really cool
relationship with her we all got to know
her she held us to a standard she was
not always nice she was always fair but
she wasn't always nice if we were doing
something poorly from a product
standpoint like we
weights and measures will let you ship
product that's heavy you just can't ship
light okay so imagine you bag your
doritos your bag of doritos is going to
be heavy it's never going to be light
now so we're thinking okay cool we have
to comply with weights and measures but
we're a health and fitness company so
people like if i'm buying 60 grams and
that's what i have in my diet plan i
want to make sure i'm eating 60 grams
and not 65. and so she would call us out
on it so we ended up buying a piece of
equipment because of that relationship
that we had with this woman that we
never met
and then one day she went silent
we wrote to her mom hey is everything
okay and her mom said she passed away
she was like
28.
and i got like really emotional and i'd
never met her and i'm not like that guy
but i got legitimately emotional and i
wrote
a manifesto and i said to everyone in
the company basically we exist to serve
these people every one of them is trying
to do something that we may know nothing
about
and they're using our products and so we
started celebrating her name's joy
ramita we've been doing it for four
years now the joyramita superfan award
we bring somebody in that's been amazing
to the community we just give them a big
blowout party at our headquarters giving
behind-the-scenes access to cool stuff
just to say thank you
and that's when we really realized it
it may not be the kind of relationship
you have with your mom or your brother
or your sister or your spouse but it's
meaningful man in a way that business
relationships haven't been since like
the local
general store and you saw the same
people come in every day it really is
like if you can flip that switch in your
mind and see it as something beautiful
i'm telling you it will open you up to a
whole new way of interacting with your
customers because there's a lot of
amazing stuff going on in your
communities that you may not even know
about or that you could really feed into
and build into something amazing and if
you stay focused on it being a community
of people that are supporting themselves
each other and your company then you can
do some pretty incredible things just
being honest even when it sucks because
let me tell you how many times it's
going to be where if you just lied
oh god it would be so much easier and
you would probably get away with it and
but it the way that i explain lying to
people is you get away with it 50 of the
time and so it tempts you to think it's
a good strategy
but the other 50 of the time it is
cratering trust
and once you can't trust the person all
hope is lost
and there's nothing more beautiful than
being in a relationship with somebody
who makes you feel like they're your
number they're number one and that you
totally trust them and lisa wrote this
um instagram post about how she could
see a photo of me with my arm around a
woman or resting my head on a woman or
hugging her or whatever and she it
wouldn't even make her radar to question
it
so
that's the fun for us is having that
level of trust now it's like um i think
it's buffett that said you spend your
entire life building your reputation
only takes five seconds to lose it so
it's like we're so careful we for 18
years we've been earning trust with each
other so like dude so especially when i
was back at quest and
it was
women would come and flirt and hit on me
because they wanted something wanted to
be sponsored by the company or whatever
and i was around bikini literal bikini
models like all the time
and so if ever there was going to be a
moment of insecurity for my wife it
would have been that period
a she wasn't insecure and b i the
thought of throwing away 18 years of
shared experience of all that trust and
everything it's sex is like rad and
super exciting and i love it the most
but like compared to what i would have
to give up for something like that it
just doesn't rate on the radar
so
and by the way thing something like i'm
saying now which most people would hide
from their spouse oh that yeah of course
i find other people attracted what are
you talking about like we just openly
talk about that like she'll nudge me and
be like oh my god do you think she's hot
it's like that's just
we set up early on in the relationship
to be aggressively ourselves and one
thing that we both were really honest
about was i was like look it is human
nature you are going to find other guys
attractive and i will actually trust you
more if you
admit when you find somebody attractive
than if you say something stupid like i
only have eyes for you oh really you're
the only human in all of history to like
uh you know transcend their human nature
like it doesn't make sense yeah and then
that's a super fragile place to be
because what happens if i get older what
happens if i get injured or scarred like
then i'm really supposed to believe that
suddenly you're more attracted to
somebody with a scar than somebody
without like it doesn't make sense so we
all live in this fragile bubble of well
as long as they lie to me it's okay and
as long as i'm willing to believe and
even though secretly i know it's a lie
and then it's the more pious than now
like oh my god she's thinking all these
nice things about me but i'm actually
finding other people attractive and i'm
just lying about it and so then you're
like wait if i'm lying about it is she
lying about it and so it just
it erodes all that trust so from the
jump we were like look you're going to
find other people attractive i'm going
to find other people attractive but let
me introduce you to this magical word
called commitment
now i'm with you because i love you
because i respect you
but i'm also with you because i'm
committed to you and so you don't have
to worry that i'm going to be looking
over my shoulder for a more attractive
woman there are going to be more
attractive women than you for sure
especially as you age
who
cares
you're my wife we have shared an
experience we've shared a life we've
built this around each other and
commitment means something to me going
back to having that code that you live
by and the rules and the code that i
live by i'm never going to betray that
yeah so it's like
we've always said i may break up with
you one day because i'm not saying that
like oh there's nothing you could do
that would make me break up with you for
sure there is but i'm never going to
cheat on you
i may come and say i'm breaking up with
you because i'm going to go have sex
with somebody else but i'm absolutely
not going to go have sex with somebody
behind your back never going to happen
so like having that trust and knowing
who the other person is like all that
stuff is is super meaningful and look
there's just more and more and more
stuff but
those are some big ones there's a gap
between who you are today
and who you will need to become
in order to execute against your why
that thing in you that's burning that
you really care about enough to get
across the finish line that you care
about enough to keep doing even when
it's making your hands cramp clothes
that you care about enough even when
you've got to come in and work between
rival gang members it's the thing that
you care about enough that you really
will work so hard
that the rival gang members fall in line
behind you because you're leading by
example
thank you
and that became my mission every day
i'm going to show up and outwork
everybody
i'm going to be the first one here i'm
going to be the last one to leave and
most importantly guys
i really hope you were listening to
robert gialdini whose books i have read
and all but memorized
the key is
you want to
connect with them you want them to fall
in love with you you want them to be
inspired you want them to feel better
about themselves when they're around you
than when they're not
and if you can pull that off they will
go to war for you think about it
if somebody is going to come after you
and they want to hurt your feelings
there is one thing every time they will
reach for
that is something that is true
when people try to hurt you they go for
the most real thing and they can jab you
right in your heart
because they know it's gonna hurt
because it's real man
and that's mean for sure and it hurts
for sure
but if you think of it like this when
somebody's throwing a rock at you with
the intention of hurting you you can put
your defenses up
you will deflect that rock never to be
seen again
or
you can lower your defenses let it hit
you in the face
knowing that it will hurt
but also knowing now at your feet is not
a rock it's a lump of gold
because they've given you an insight
into where you are weak
now once you know where you are weak
you can begin to build yourself
and that is my thesis on life
you get to build yourself in any
direction you want in any way to become
anything you want
there will be an extraordinary price to
pay
but you can go in any direction
fulfillment is what matters
it is a neurochemistry state
the game that you're playing is not
success it is not money it is not legacy
it is
neurochemistry it's feeling good about
yourself right now today in this moment
now
the absolute foundational building block
to fulfillment is progress now it i
don't mean progress in worldly pursuits
i mean humans are an active species that
are absolutely designed
to learn
adapt and grow
we are the ultimate adaptation machine
now when nature wants us to do something
it incentivizes that thing with pleasure
so
if we're the ultimate adaptation machine
designed to learn grow and get better
then it's going to make that process
intensely pleasurable now
what it doesn't incentivize is
the
obsession over where other people are
whether or not we have unique ideas
whether or not we're valuable none of
that is going to bring you joy okay as
they say comparison is the thief of joy
so hey if you really want to [ __ ] with
yourself jump in the instagram feed and
look how other people are crushing it
and obsess over that
if on the other hand you want to
really have a deep and lasting sense of
fulfillment jump in the instagram feed
find people that motivate and inspire
you to be a better version of yourself
not to attain worldly success but to
actuate your potential to ask yourself a
very simple question what is it that i
am excited by what am i motivated by
what jazzes me up regardless of whether
or not it jazz is anybody else up and
now i'm gonna go get good at that thing
and that progress is the foundational
building block of happiness how do you
feel about yourself
when you're by yourself
i know a lot of people that fear
that quiet
i know a lot of people that don't want
to be alone with themselves
and the reason they don't want to be
alone with themselves
is because they don't
think
they're worthwhile
they're not happy with who they are
that's what adaptation is about
if you're not happy with who you are
then let's step into the ownership of
that let's remember that's our fault
there's no one else to blame for that
the people that did horrible things to
you are not to blame for that
because if they are there's nothing you
can do
but if you're
the owner of that
in fact don't even worry about the word
blame you're in control that's what this
is about it's about retaining control
it's about knowing that you own your
life and at any time if you want a
different outcome you can make different
decisions you can do different things
you can start a new narrative
and once you begin that new narrative
you realize the power that's in that to
take you where you want to go
the american dream is still alive for
anybody if you're willing
to learn and grow first of all if you're
willing to accept you're not yet the
person you need to be to execute at the
highest level you're willing to
acknowledge your deficits and understand
what skills you need and then go out and
relentlessly acquire those skills that
have utility and then be willing to put
that those skills to the test against
something for me the test is business
it's the test i enjoy it's not the test
everyone enjoys but that's what quest
was largely me asking and answering the
question am i acquiring the right skills
in order to end metabolic disease yes or
no and if the answer was no i changed as
epictetus said he is a wise man who does
not grieve for things which he has not
but rejoices for those which he has
and that's gratitude isn't it
it's the very base decision that we all
have to make
are you grateful for the things you have
in your life or are you always wanting
more and trust me i get it
i understand people that strive for more
i understand people that want something
bigger and better but at the same time
if you allow yourself to only think
about what you don't have to only be
striving for something more that that
obsession will begin to overtake you it
will begin to corrode you
but ultimately it's a choice ultimately
at any time right now in this moment you
can stop
and think about what you have you can
put your attention on the things you're
grateful for and watch what it does
watch what it does in that instance the
way that it changes you the way that it
changes your chemistry your feelings in
a moment
can shift from negative
and dark
to
beautiful
with nothing else changing around you
nothing but you deciding
that you're going to focus on the things
you're grateful for nothing but deciding
that there are things in your life to be
grateful for and that is a decision no
matter what is happening in your life at
any moment right now in the depths of a
depression in something going on
terribly in your life you can choose
right now
to think about the things you're
grateful for
the breeze
a smile from somebody kind a stranger
who holds open a door for you anything
but it's a choice
and as einstein said there are only two
ways to live your life
one is as though nothing is a miracle
the other
is as though everything is a miracle
and what choice are you making
what are you choosing to focus on right
now
do you let gratitude fill you up or not
and here's the critical part and i want
you to listen to this really well
whatever you decide whether you decide
we live in a world of miracles or
whether you decide we live in a world
devoid of miracles you are choosing one
thing to the exclusion of the other and
when you focus on something that you're
grateful for when you look at those
little moments in your life and choose
to see them as grand miracles even when
it is only a gentle hand on your
shoulder even when it's only a kiss from
somebody who you've kissed a thousand
times before even when it is only
holding the hand of somebody who needed
their hand held even when it's something
that simple
[Music]
it really is a miracle that it really is
something that can fill you it really is
something that will change your
chemistry bring a connection between two
people allow you to see a grander vista
or even just open a window and look out
at the world and realize that you're
alive that this is all
a miracle that none of this is
guaranteed that every breath you take
could be your last
and in that
you can choose to cherish
what you have in that you can decide to
focus on
that you have a breath to take
and even when it's something that simple
when you train your mind to do that when
you train yourself to decide to see the
beauty in that
then nobody can ever take it away from
you
and no matter where you are
no matter what's going on in your life
you'll be able to rise up and feel
the beauty
that is being alive
so take a minute
at the worst times in your life
and focus on the things you're grateful
for so
for eight and a half years i'm doing
that i am working seven days a week
ignoring my wife at about the six and a
half year mark my wife pulls me aside
and says you're now damaging our
marriage and i'm not willing to continue
like this so it's like all right
something's got to give and that forced
me to really look and say i'm profoundly
unhappy and showing up every day chasing
money just isn't actually who i am and i
need to do something that makes me feel
alive in the moment
so
it ends up being a cool part of my story
but what i want people to know is when
the following thing happened i was a
wash in shame and so there i was the guy
going hard by this point i've worked my
way up now i'm the chief marketing
officer of the company i own 10 of it um
all just through sweat equity they made
good on their promise
and
i was so
broken inside and so unhappy that i was
like i have to leave i need to go back
to filmmaking i need to do something
that in in and of itself like i will
love and be passionate about and what i
realized was the struggle is guaranteed
the success is not now at that time i
was a multi-millionaire on paper but as
you well know being rich on paper is
very different than having money in your
bank no doubt about it so i was rich on
paper i did not feel rich and so i was
like what am i doing all of this for so
my wife and i talk and i'm like look i
know i promised i would make you rich
and i swear to god i will one day but
i'm gonna have to take a step backwards
first because i can't just muscle
through like this i'm i'm just losing so
many years of my life i need to do
something that if i'm gonna fail at
least i'm gonna fail loving what i'm
doing she was totally behind me she said
what are now famous words in our
marriage she said i bet on you
i was like that means a lot so i go in
and i quit
and i said look here's your equity back
i'm not going to cross the finish line
so i don't think i should get anything
for this so
you know take it and do your thing and
i'm gonna go to greece we're gonna move
to greece and i'm gonna write and that's
that and they said look we could do this
without you but we don't want to
and so what would it take for us to keep
working together and i laid out a plan
of
if whatever i'm going to be doing next
it's got to be around value creation
it's got to be around passion it's got
to be something that we would love every
day even if we were failing i want to
build community i want to be myself and
i said look this thing that we now call
social media wasn't called that back
then but
social media i think is going to change
everything what year is that this is
20 2009. okay
so i'm like i think this is going to
change everything going to change the
way that people do business and actually
this probably was a little bit earlier
than that um
so the next company i want to be
transparent i want our real personality
personalities to shine through i want
people to see like we actually want good
things for you
and so that for three very different
reasons became the core of what we
wanted to do and so we founded quest
nutrition everyone told us we were crazy
that we were leaving technology like the
place where people actually get rich and
going into food the place where you're
in manufacturing it's going to be small
margins you guys are never going to
survive this and so everyone thought we
were done but our thing was we're never
going to make decisions based on
profitability again we're going to be
making it based on like actually adding
value to people's lives being passionate
about what we do every day and loving
our lives and so we actually made a
promise to each of us and we said you're
going to enjoy what you do on a
day-to-day basis simple as and so if
it's something weird like when i started
doing inside quest
fine like even if it's not like we don't
see the immediate roi in the business if
you love it and that's a part of what's
making you a complete and full human
being then let's do it so we got into
really crazy stuff but ended up being
amazing
um because we made that promise to each
other so that was how all of that began
and then we just really lived up to it
about value creation about not just
trying to sell people on something about
building a real community to uplift
people and it just so happened that we
had the right product at the right time
marketed in a totally new way because of
my background in film we were creating
all of our own content in-house we built
an entire studio inside the company we
were shooting everything long before
that was like a thing it was like we
were doing that and everyone was like
this is crazy but then we grow by 57 000
in our first three years alone
in manufacturing people don't have
enough rules in their life for
themselves so for instance i get out of
bed in 10 minutes or less doesn't matter
and i don't want to that's why i have
the rule because i call us your mind
literally i went through a period where
i would lay in bed for three to four
hours awash in shame and my inability to
get out of bed and it just embarrassed
me and so i felt badly about myself so i
wanted to make a change so i knew that i
needed a bright line so bright line 10
minutes or less you get out of bed as
soon as you realize you're awake that's
it so and the rule is more specific it's
like i have to have had at least five
hours of sleep um
but once you put the rule in place then
you just live by it and that's how you
earn credibility like right now i don't
feel the way telling you that that i
want to feel this is a good moment he's
on my team i'm pointing at him this is a
good moment so i'm saying this and i
don't feel good about saying it why
because today i don't know what happened
i got out of bed in 11 minutes and i was
literally time it oh yeah i mean from
waking up to actually physically getting
out of the bed correct my feet must be
on the floor and i must be standing up
before it ticks over into the 11th
minute and today i don't know what
happened i i was i was aware of the time
i knew i needed to get up and for
whatever reason one of the minutes just
went faster than i thought when i looked
back i was like damn it and so i'm
surprised you even made it here today
then right so now this comes into like
knowing how to handle something like
that like if you totally fall apart
because you don't live up 20 rules
you're violating another one of my rules
which is don't do anything that doesn't
move you towards your goals so it's like
yes i it is a part of my identity to
confess this so because i'm talking
about it i want to say it now to an
audience it's the only thing that will
allow me to reset and be able to feel
good about it again because i don't lie
when i miss it i own it
well look if your biggest problem is it
took you 11 minutes to get out sadly
that's not my biggest problem this is a
high quality program right yes very true
but my thing is people don't have the
rules
and so i have other rules for instance i
wear a size 32 pant that's just that's
it and so no matter what your waist is
no no i won't let my waist get out of
line with that so i use the pants as a
way to guide now i would go down if i
got so lean that i was you know 31
that's not a problem but i'm not going
to allow myself to go up and it's super
tempting like especially around
christmas i don't try to hold abs
through the winter so
during christmas like right now i do not
have abs so and i'm totally fine with
that i switch a different part of my
mentality i during the holidays my wife
and i definitely celebrate with food and
it's amazing and i love it the most so
but if that celebration took me up to
like 32s don't fit anymore i gotta come
back because i have a rule so it's like
that's how i keep myself
in a lane i keep myself from getting
into trouble i know the things that i
accept for myself and what i don't
accept for myself and it's all like
stated it's very clear
self-reward and self-punishment is
really really important yes and
you
i think that if people don't sort of
automatically have the guilty thing
which they probably do it's more a
willingness to lean into that and to say
okay this is actually going to serve me
this is going to work for me and i
actually do wonder sometimes you know
somebody who now
basically has a profession of giving
advice at least on on the one side of
what i do
and so i think a lot about like who
should actually take my advice because
my advice is not going to lead to a
carefree easy life
lisa was just saying she was laying in
bed last night thinking about me and she
said how does he do it
because there's there's just a level of
things that i'm willing to take on and i
don't one i'm not even sure it's healthy
for me and two i'm certainly not certain
that it's healthy for other people but
what i do know is that i have a level of
thrill
and pleasurable obsession around it so
for me it's fun so when i think about
the the guilt or the momentary pain of
something up and you talk about me
getting better as a speaker it's like
that journey is
it is a very simple journey that
requires you though to really accept
that you're not very good at things
right now and that that's fine and so a
big key for me has always been to think
of my life not in
the len not the lens of a moment
and i used to tell this to my employees
all the time like stop judging yourself
through the lens of a moment and start
judging yourself through the lens of 10
years if you think of yourself in 10
year increments like you will blow your
mind so if you're embarrassed today
about where you are don't compare
yourself even to yesterday which may not
soothe that and encourage you to push
forward think back 10 years
my gut instinct is unless you've really
been treading water in which case then
leverage that pain to never do that
again but if you think back to where you
were 10 years chances are like you're
going to be blown away with how far you
come and so then it's like all right
then i'm just going to focus my gaze ten
years in the future and start saying
what would i have to do
to
be somewhere where i'd be blown away
then with where i'm at now yeah but it
really does require you to
say okay i'm the the pride that i'm
going to establish is actually around my
willingness to look at the fact that i'm
not good right now today you have to
fight to reach your dream you have to
sacrifice and work hard for it
that's coming from the man who has come
to define natural talent
but that's what other people put on him
people want to see somebody who's just
naturally talented it's god-given they
were graced they were blessed with
something at birth
but what does he say when he's asked
about what it took to become the person
that he is
it took hard work it took sacrifice it
took giving things up it took doubling
down it took pushing himself every day
day after day and that's the thing about
hard work
when you put that kind of unending
blinding effort into something it gets
to the point where you've worked so hard
that it looks like magic that people
would sooner believe that it's dna that
it's gifted that it is god-given than to
believe
that they would have to work that hard
to replicate it but if you can stop
making other people extraordinary as a
way to let yourself off the hook then
you too can become extraordinary all of
us are capable of far more than we think
we're capable of more than the people
who love us the most think we are
capable of more than the people who hate
us the most would have us
believe at the end of the day
it is a very simple question you're
going to have to ask yourself
and answer for yourself
how hard are you willing to work
how much are you willing to sacrifice
but on the other side of that is power
and energy and as kyle rowe jr said if
you're attacking you don't get as tired
as when you're chasing
and that's the key
when you
know what you want and when you will not
be held back from getting it suddenly
you go on the offensive it's not about
pleasing somebody else it's not about
chasing somebody else becoming them or
even beating them it is about yourself
knowing what you want and attacking it
going after it and not letting anybody
dissuade you it is looking at yourself
and recognizing how you have to improve
to get that good but you've got to
hunger for that goal you've got to
hunger to get across and win you've got
to want that
the way that a man whose head is on fire
wants a pond
and when you get to that stage when
you're able to cultivate something in
yourself like that something that is
refusing to be extinguished something
that will be heard something that will
stand up and be counted
then you're going to have what you need
to get the skills that you need to move
forward to win to attack and in that
attack and having the energy to move
forward relentlessly
you will find that even though you're
working harder than you've ever worked
in your life
you're more energized than you've ever
been in your life
the times where you fatigue
they're not the times you're working the
hardest
the times you fatigue are when you're
being least yourself
you're not being true to who you are and
what you want
so right now
right now
start being honest
about what it is you're willing to
attack
start being honest about who you want to
be what you're willing to become and the
price you're willing to pay to get there
if you give yourself over to that
you will not be able to be stopped if
you want to do something extraordinary
you have one job
leave your fellow humans in awe
now when you think about holy sh my job
as a parent as an entrepreneur as an
athlete as a speaker as a whatever you
want to be
you've got to get so good at that thing
that when people see you do it
you make them experience the most potent
human emotion and that is awe
to get that good
is a terrifying journey of
self-discovery
and confronting who you really are
because you cannot make change until you
acknowledge where you're actually at
now why
because it's not some
new age woo thing it is for real like if
you understand where you're weak then
you know where to spend your time
building skills
to me the gap between where you are now
and where you want to go is a gap of
skill set
and once i realized that and i made the
choice
to believe that this whole brain
plasticity thing was real even though it
was being hotly debated then i could
shift my self-esteem
from being smart
right
good
worthy
to being that of the learner
the learner is the only identity that i
have ever found
that is anti-fragile
as naseem teleb says things that are
robust that are strong that are tough
that can take just a lot of abuse before
they break they are still ultimately
defined by their breaking point
something that is anti-fragile on the
other hand is something that the more
you attack it the more it is pounded on
the stronger it gets
now imagine being able to build
a belief system
the thing that you build your
self-esteem around if all of that
we're tied to something that is truly
anti-fragile that the more somebody
comes after it the more robust it
becomes
being a learner is that answer we went
through a whole debate about what is the
next company going to be and it was one
of those where it had to be something
that we cared about you know we had
started this whole gyration of selling
the technology company because i was so
pissed
and so tired of chasing money and i
wanted to do something that i believed
in i wanted to do something that
mattered that had impact so
the only reason that i was interested in
getting into nutrition was because i
felt that it one it could save the two
people that i was most worried about in
the world and two i thought that it
could address what i saw as the greatest
health the greatest health crisis we
face as a species quite frankly there's
a difference between happiness and
fulfillment a bowl of ice cream brings
me happiness
it does not bring me fulfillment
fulfillment is often born of suffering
fulfillment is about doing the things
that are hard in fact the greeks have a
word for it it's called technique
technique means that you acquire a set
of skills that is unique to you the
acquisition of those skills was very
difficult and here's the important part
those skills
serve other people
to me i believe that the very
reason that we're all here
is to see how many skills we can acquire
that have utility
and then put that utility to the test in
service of others
that's going to be the thing that lights
you on fire you're busting your ass
you're really getting good at something
you are taking action you're moving
forward you're doing the things you need
to learn to do to learn and trigger that
adaptation response that humans have
you're putting yourself under this
stress you've identified a goal you're
working your way backwards
to where you are today
and that's the key now building yourself
begins with intention
clarity you have to know who you want to
become
you can't just show up in the gym of the
mind and do random stuff any more than
you can show up in the gym of the body
and do random stuff and think that
you're going to end up on the stage
competing for mr olympia
it doesn't work like that you've got to
have this clarity of focus and the way
that i always explain it to people
people come to me all the time and
they're like tom
i want to help people man
and i'm like that is rad that's coming
from such a beautiful place but telling
me that you want to help somebody is
like saying you want to win a gold medal
in what
the olympics
yes fantastic summer or winter summer
great tennis are swimming swimming which
event
backstroke the medley because until you
know exactly in what way you are trying
to serve people you don't know what
skills you need to acquire in order to
leave people in awe so that you may
become extraordinary
skills have utility learning how to swim
better makes you a faster swimmer
building certain muscles in your arms
and in your shoulders
all of the different things that go into
getting great at any sport all of those
things must be learned with calculation
they must be practiced and rehearsed
over and over and over you have to push
yourself long past the point of boredom
boredom kills more people in the pursuit
of success than any hater will ever kill
boredom is the great killer of dreams
boredom
because people don't have the focus they
don't have the clarity of what they're
trying to achieve they've not built into
their life built
into their life an intoxication for what
they're trying to accomplish first of
all each and every one of you needs to
avoid what kevin kelly calls premature
optimization then you need to go out and
experience a whole lot of stuff now
premature optimization is where somebody
thinks off the jump oh this thing i'm
kind of interested in that i'm gonna
optimize my life for that thing
the reason this happens is god forbid
you went to a high school where they
already already made you choose like
more or less a major which they do in
the uk and i think it's problematic and
some schools do here in the us
then certainly by the time you get to
college everyone is forcing you they
want you to pick a major
then when you get out you've got to get
a job and you want to get a job that
makes sense with the major that you just
got she took on all this debt you spent
all this time and so that's premature
optimization you literally made a
decision when you were 18 maybe 17
terrifying and now the whole rest of
your life is an echo of that random
decision you made before your brain was
finished developing think about that for
a second your brain doesn't stop
developing until you're 25. so at 18
and that's late honestly most people are
thinking about it at 17 or even 16
you're making a decision you're
prematurely optimizing you haven't
experienced enough stuff you don't know
what really lights that initial spark of
interest and so you go down this path
you're it you're at 25 you're having a
quarter life crisis because you don't
love what you do it's a mess so
my advice
is to go experience a whole lot of
things now whether that's taking a gap
year which i would never have done um so
trust me when i say that's not your only
option but you need to be experiencing a
lot of stuff trying a lot of things
taking a lot of classes watching videos
tutorials reading learning like figuring
out what it is you go whoa i really like
that thing it's not a passion it's not
gonna spark off like that it's just
experience you find something ah it
piques your curiosity you're more
interested in that than the next thing
okay now we're going to engage with it
this is step two engagement is different
than just going and experiencing so
that's sort of a a very non-committal
dilettante sort of way of involving
yourself with something just
experiencing it the next is i really
like this and i'm going to go hard on it
so if i took a dance class now i'm going
to sign up for a year's worth of dance
classes or something i'm going to start
going and i'm really going to see if i
like this and in that engagement process
where you're starting to read about it
you're talking to other people about it
you're going to find out if the more you
get into it the more you're like whoa
this went from an interest to like a
real fascination fascination is that
next
gate if it turns into a fascination and
you're like whoa the more i learn about
this more i want to learn and the more
that i get just excited about this the
more energy it gives me okay that's a
good chance then that that thing can
become a passion now we're going to go
through the process of actually gaining
mastery now i think passion is like love
meaning it needs to be a reciprocal
thing so as you go down the process of
gaining mastery those skills need to
then be useful in the real world and the
echo that you get back from the real
world that those skills are valuable to
other people the more you're gonna be
like whoa i feel good about myself so
now you had something that was
interesting it turned into a fascination
the more you engaged with it and now as
you gain skills you're actually able to
serve other people who then give you
that positive reinforcement where you're
like whoa not only am i getting good at
this like that getting good has real
world utility and it impacts other
people and then they echo that back and
that makes me feel really good about
myself so i enjoy it in and of itself
and i enjoy that element of technique
where as a social species i am helping
other parts of my tribe and that feels
really good and it's something that
other people value that is the passion
now fanning the flames is a slightly
different thing to the side of that
which is in that process which i think
it starts pretty early probably starts
back at the interest phase as you get
interested in something you're going to
start doing things like what i'm doing
right
now
two seconds before the camera started
rolling i was not talking like this i
did not have this energy level i wasn't
using my hands as much or my face is
much oddly enough
but embodying something is absolutely
critical so a big part of gaining a
passion is telling other people what
you're up to allowing yourself to embody
the excitement telling yourself and
other people that you're excited about
it and actually embodying that
excitement embodying that passion which
then your brain goes whoa we're getting
really excited about this you know we're
our volume is getting higher we're
getting more energetic we're moving more
all of that stuff forces the brain to
say this must actually be really
important and when you start doing that
then you're beginning to hardwire your
brain for that and you're beginning to
associate the emotion with that thing
that you're doing it is something that
you can very much do
as long as based on something real i
find that this is pretty ineffective if
there isn't that real core level of
interest but if you have that real core
level of interest then all of a sudden
everything that you do just magnifies
that over and over and over i don't go
oh that's interesting brightline i go
okay that's interesting i want to
explore that more what would that look
like how would that serve me what would
it really feel like for me
how's it playing out in my life does it
actually have real world implications
and this isn't all something that i sit
down in one quick session like that's
what i'm thinking about i may think
about it for
weeks a month more six months who knows
and it depends on what kind of impact
that it's going to have in my life so i
don't you don't lead with bright lines
to create a habit let's be really clear
about that so habits are something
different getting in routines and habits
is a place to start and then if you find
like i have a morning routine i have
habits that i do every morning but they
they are things that i'm very flexible
on that creates a lot of um mobility in
my life if i wake up late or something
like that then i'll just shave this out
or the other bright lines like i
if i have a bright line i don't with my
bright lines i do my bright lines so
that's the whole point of a bright line
they are absolutely non-negotiable so
be very careful about what you put
bright lines around make sure it is
something that's leading you towards
your goal
and i think better to make it a habit
and a routine first and see if it
actually has an advantage if it's
something that's important and if it's
something that you struggle with and
think that it's really really important
and you need that bright line elon musk
talks about in his business it's all
about breaking things down to the
physics
if you sell to people
the physics in your world is psychology
and understanding what motivates them
so your company needs to have a why
if you know simon sinek and his
brilliant book start with why
you'll know what we're talking about the
golden circle
most people know what they do they may
even know how they do it but they
oftentimes don't know why they do it
why did we launch quest nutrition
because we wanted to end metabolic
disease
nobody knew that from looking at a
protein bar
but our marketing material was about
that
we didn't do features and benefits we
said stop sacrificing
we said you should hold food companies
to a new standard it's ridiculous
that food companies aren't
engineering new equipment to make food
that's both good for you
and delicious
it's just ridiculous nobody's held their
feet to the fire people have been buying
the same junk products for years they're
not going to change unless you force
them to and so we came along and said
we're going to be the bearer of
standards
we know why we're doing what we're doing
so i can't release a product that has
sugar in it why because that's not going
to end metabolic disease and that is my
driver i show up to work every day not
thinking about making it rain and
counting my money i'm not swimming in it
like scrooge mcduck i'm coming every day
thinking about two people my mom and my
sister
and i ask a very simple question is this
advantageous for my mom and my sister
yes or no if it is i do it if it's not i
don't now a lot of times what's
advantageous for my mom and my sister
was really expensive it was super
annoying to have to do it because it was
like you watching margins like oh god
but it becomes an easy filter and every
business has to have a filter every
business needs to know what they say yes
to and what they say no to and if you
don't have that blinding guiding light
when you scale you will fall apart
and the reason you will fall apart your
customers won't know who you are they
won't know how to communicate your
message to somebody else your employees
won't know who you are they won't know
what to communicate to each other let
alone the outside world
so it has got to be blinding you have to
be able to write it down it has to be
super clear it's got to be direct and
it's got to be meaningful
and it has to be real
it's got to actually be something that
drives you so we all come to a
relationship with like expectations
about how we think people should act and
unfortunately we don't recognize our
expectations as expectations we
recognize them as truth this is how the
world is it is how the world should be
and when somebody we think that they
have those same beliefs and values and
rules and all that and so given this
scenario there's only one way to act
that is certainly obvious and so when
the person doesn't act like that we take
it personally like whoa do you not
respect me do you not love me do you not
care about me and it just isn't that
they have a different set of beliefs and
rules there's enough nuance difference
that they're not if they're intending to
hurt you you have a whole different set
of problems but assuming that they're
not intending to hurt you then you have
a communication problem so lisa and i
actually define our terms so we have a
few words in our
marriage that they mean something so if
i say hey baby it's important to me that
you leave that you know glass of water
on the table
then there she just wouldn't move it
period simple as like
the the word important like comes in all
caps with exclamation points glowing red
like that's like when we say it like
it's a drop whatever you're doing like
it's important that you do x y z now the
big thing is when you define a word like
that you can't ever abuse it so like i
would never say it's important to me
that you leave you know it's got to be
it's just extraordinary like how many
times do i tell her something's
important in a year
i don't know six seven times in a year
so it's like it's really got to be
limited and then another one is promise
if i say i promise i'm gonna do that
dude i'm going to
do
that like there's no two ways about it
so you never throw around promise ever
under any circumstance and so dude it's
like you really really have to be
hardcore and so and the other way that
we use promise is um if
if uh she says you know how does this
dress look on me i'm like yeah it looks
great and she's like you promise
then it's like all right all right it
makes you look fat what can i say you
know what i mean it's like but then you
you cut to like the chase on something
now the thing is you can't say that all
the time you can't be like how's this
dress make me look fine promise uh what
do you think of this dinner you like it
yeah i love it promise like if you're
doing that it loses everything but if
you're saving it for like in fact god i
almost don't remember the last time i
asked lisa to promise something like
that um but
you know that you haven't we certainly
use it more in the early days of our
marriage but even then like how many
times a year three or four i mean it's
like but it really forces you to respect
these things you make sacred in your
relationship the number one question i
get and i get this question so much you
can't imagine how do i find my passion
the good news is
passion is not something that's handed
to you it is not a lightning bolt moment
it's another nice simple mathematical
equation first of all you need to
identify your areas of interest
everybody's interested in something and
i find the big problem is people stop
themselves because they say yeah well
the thing that i'm interested in
couldn't possibly be a business so let's
take video games back in the 80s
back when everybody thought the video
games were a joke
you're ruining your brain it's like
intellectual candy
kids get off the computer go play
outside nintendo's a joke it's
ridiculous and then we have an entire
industry now that's born up around video
games that has made untold numbers of
millionaires i met one of the founders
of riot games that created league of
legends the guy guys like i don't know
31 maybe younger i mean just crazy they
do a billion dollars a billion dollars
in revenue
for micro transactions
of things that are not essential to play
the game the game is totally free to
play you don't need to pay for anything
imagine that for a second you're in an
industry where they don't need to buy
anything to get full use of your game
and yet you do over a billion dollars in
revenue because they said i love this i
like being around games i like the
competition of it i think it's amazing
i'm gonna find a way i'm gonna be
inventive i'm gonna look for areas to
add value
and so they have and more people now
watch esports the finale of league of
legends then watch the finales i think
of all major sports combined
it's crazy they fill arenas
it's absolutely bonkers but that was
somebody who said this is something i
love it's something i want to be around
it is an area of interest and i don't
care if other people tell me that it
can't be a business it's what i want to
be around with enough ingenuity
and enough for thought into what
actually can be a business because some
things can't
you can really do something with
something that's an interest all right
so an interest you need to gain mastery
in it during the process of gaining
mastery you'll find out whether you
actually like that thing enough to
become great at it it is my belief
whatever it is you set out to do as a
business there should be one litmus test
you should be able to ask and
affirmatively answer the following
question
do i want to know more about this than
anyone else in the world
don't get into something unless you plan
to be the best that's my piece of advice
i know that's not going to sit well with
everybody
but if you want to have the passion to
make something big
to make big change it's got to be
something that you believe in beyond
reasonable doubt it's got to be
something you've just got to make happen
so ask yourself do i want to know more
about this than anyone else because
you're going to have to get better at it
than anyone else if you want to be
excellent and deliver on the promise
they're very concrete habits that you
can use that i have used once you get
your mind in the right place once you
believe that it can happen
this is what i did i worked out why
because it helped me gain control of my
mind one it was micro credibility with
myself every day i said i was gonna do
something i did it two when you're
suffering and you're willing to fight
through it you tell yourself a story
that you're willing to pay the price to
become what you want to become and also
and this may be the most important
reason each and every one of you should
start working out and it has nothing to
do with living longer because we could
get hit by a meteorite who knows so i'm
not even worried about that but i am
worried about this
when you watch your body transform you
get the loudest signal from your
subconscious that you can change that
you can change anything you want that
you can change your bicep your tricep
your quad whatever it is you want
something that you literally could not
do the day before you can do today
and your mind sees that that's true
your mind sees that something you
couldn't pick up yesterday you can pick
up today
and it begins to ask itself well if
that's possible then what else is
possible
now for me finding my center was also a
very important thing so i work out first
the next thing i do without fail is
meditate
i do a just breathe meditation where i'm
simply trying to calm my mind
then i do what i call thinkitating
during meditating i get into an alpha
wave state brain pattern which enhances
creativity and unique connections i'm
not worried about whether i'll ever
think a unique thought i am simply
interested in the unique connections
that i will make that no one else before
me or after me will ever make because
their circumstances are different than
mine and that to me is what makes each
of us a beautiful snowflake
is we're all going to make connections
that other people might not make and so
during thinking i take advantage of a
problem i'm trying to solve i smash it
together with my alpha wave state and i
see what comes out of it i read i read
obsessively
because i believe in one simple math
equation ideas in equal ideas out and
then i keep a list of the most important
things i'm trying to accomplish if
you're trying to become something you
need to know what that something is i am
not a born entrepreneur now there are
many people that consider themselves a
born entrepreneur i am not one of them i
know that there were kids out there
that had lemonade stands when they were
like six months old they couldn't hold
their head up but they could sell that
was not me i was totally [ __ ] when
it came to stuff like that i had a paper
route
and they gave your money in two ways one
they just gave you sort of a blanket
weekly payment for delivering the paper
but then the other part of it was you
were supposed to go collect that money
and i was too afraid to knock on the
doors to collect the money so i never
got that part but i felt so obligated
that i said i would do it that i kept
delivering the papers essentially for
free
so that's where i started as an
entrepreneur my parents biggest
frustration was that i was epically lazy
and if they handed out gold medals for
being lazy i would have won i assure you
hands down
there was a period in my life where i
would spend between two and three hours
in bed because it was warm in bed and it
was cold out of bed
all right that's true i actually did an
interview with jocko willink if you guys
know him extreme ownership his book
totally blew me away and in the middle
of the interview i confessed that and he
said tom don't worry we'll let you edit
that out and i said jocko i don't i
actually don't want to edit that out
because right now the narrative about
what it means to be an entrepreneur
is to be naturally gifted
and i call total on that
because i'm not naturally gifted i don't
have any natural talents and all of us
are born as this lump of jelly that
can't hold its own head up that poos in
its pants
and we all learn to do things and it's
that ability to specialize that makes us
great and the things that you choose to
put your time and energy into those are
going to be the things that allow you to
accomplish something but all of that is
a choice i heard a quote one time and it
so terrifies me this in fact
over a long enough time period people
are going to hear this quote from me so
many times because seriously man i'm not
joking this scares me
and it scares me enough that it it has a
daily place in my life and that is
genius is a young man's game
and when i heard that quote i thought
whoa the one thing that all of us touch
for the briefest of moments is youth
and if you're lucky what you'll get is a
whole lot of middle age and then some
old age but you don't get a lot of youth
and so i just thought oh that's really
scary and they were basing it on the
number of people that win nobel prizes
it's almost always for work they did in
their 20s and 30s almost always
and i thought i don't like that and so
looking at why that and the reason i
guess this is important to say the
reason that i didn't like it was i felt
that my youth was really whipping by and
i hadn't accomplished the things that i
wanted to accomplish so
if i'm you know my youth is wishing by
me how do i make sure that i can access
genius at any time that an on a genius
shorthand for like playing at the
absolute best of your game and really
changing things like really having an
impact and this is one thing i think you
and i share like
no
i want to have impact in the world so um
if i just wanted to be rich lisa and i
would have bought an island and retired
you know years ago um so
clearly there's something more that's
motivating me and that thing is impact
and really touching lives so it's like
wanting to be able to do that i don't
want to say well i had this brief window
in my youth and either did or didn't
make use of it but even if i did i don't
want the rest of my life to be looking
back on that so another quote that
drives me your future should always be
bigger than your past so all right
you've got genius as a young man's game
and a personal belief of mine that you
you should always be looking towards
doing something more than you've ever
done and so you put those two together
and i just knew i had to
solve for that problem
and the only solution that i have for it
is switching things up like you said to
live at the edges and the same book was
talking about the people that do end up
getting either multiple nobel prizes or
prizes for work they did later is it's
people that would routinely change so
that they would have these two
overlapping areas so like chemistry and
physics and like where those two meet
like there's new discoveries and new
ways to challenge your own thinking and
so
always staying fresh always challenging
my own thinking always looking at how am
i wrong
most people go into an endeavor with the
confirmation bias in fact you just
brought that up so it's like i'm so
aware that by nature like everybody i
just want to be told how right i am how
amazing the way that i'm thinking is and
because it feels good right that feels
awesome now you've had like i have
you've had extraordinary people sitting
across from me i've been blessed to have
you sit across from me today and i'm
curious
if there was a common
uh denominator between all of these
people or what have you learned that
surprised you in doing the show so far
the thing that's really surprised me is
that it is so consistent that which is
what the what what has made them all
successful and their ability to
articulate it they use different words
some people come at it from different
angles everybody has something fresh at
any moment this is so important at any
moment you can choose to believe
something new about yourself now the
weird thing about belief is as soon as
you change that belief it becomes true
why that is i will never quite
understand what weird quirk of human
evolution has left us in a space where
simply believing it makes it true if you
think you're dumb guess what you're dumb
truly and you will act in accordance
with that belief and that should scare
the [ __ ] out of you because it scared
the life out of me and i saw myself
heading down a path that i did not want
to be on because i believed that i was
dumb i had a fixed mindset i used to
only apply for jobs where i knew i'd be
smarter than the person interviewing me
because i did not want to feel badly
about myself but you can imagine the
types of jobs that i got
i once lovingly referred to myself as
the king of remedial jobs
and i actually had pride in that because
what i built my sense of pride around
was getting the job was always being
smart was being right and none of those
things were moving me towards my goals
now if you don't know this quote live by
it one can have no smaller or greater
mastery than mastery over oneself that's
da vinci da vinci did amazing things
with his life i wanted to do equally
amazing things with mine and if that's
the game that we're playing if i can
construct my belief system if i can
choose at any moment
to believe something that's more
empowering
than i was believing the moment before
and that that will actually find its way
into my actions
allow me to do things that i couldn't do
the moment before
then it's like that moment in the matrix
where nia realizes he knows kung fu
and that's like as funny as that is
that's how i think about life to me the
very fundamental purpose of life
is to find out how many skills
i can acquire
that have utility
and then put that utility to the test in
service
of something greater than myself and i
used to say to myself all the time
you're gonna get rich or you're gonna
die trying
and so
starting as a copywriter i started
busting my ass step number one i
convinced my wife
we're going to because there were two
other partners that hired me
i'm gonna pick an apartment that's no
more than five minutes from either of
them
that way if they call me at two in the
morning i'll be there in five minutes
and they're gonna know no one else in
their company is as serious as me
and i'm gonna claw my way up this
company and i'm gonna get whatever job
i become the right person for and i'm
going to work my way up and by the time
we ended up selling that company i had
clawed my way through sweat equity into
owning 10 percent of the company and
being the chief marketing officer from
starting as the copywriter
the person that everybody asked who's
the kid in the server room
was the only person that didn't have a
window they literally put me in the room
with all the computer servers
but starting from there i knew i could
wow people because i was willing to
grind it out
and that is one of the most valuable
things that anybody can do only
execution matters
burn that into your nervous system get a
tattoo do whatever you need to do to
remind yourself
only execution matters
thinking about it feeling good about it
those are awesome but if you have a
vision of something you're trying to do
become whatever and you don't execute
against it and i don't need you to want
to build a big business if you tell me
you want to be the greatest parent of
all time then i'm going to ask you what
are you doing to execute on that goal
what are you doing how do you define it
what are your deliverables what are the
metrics by which you're judging yourself
and by the way if you don't want a grand
goal you don't need one but then say
what i'm trying to do is get centered
i'm trying to experience happiness even
that you can begin to look at ways that
you can improve that
now i very much subscribe to the theory
that the human animal is an active
species meaning it will forever be
moving forward i think that's a good
thing it's one of the most exciting
things in my life and i have three fears
one brain damage that freaks me out two
losing my wife because damn that woman's
cool and then three i don't ever want to
feel like i've hit the end of what i can
do i always want to feel like there's
something more that i can learn and grow
into
so keeping in mind execution is how you
get there no matter what your path is
and in the beginning
when all we could do because we didn't
know production we just had to throw
human capital at it and i needed people
there not kidding
at 2am on a friday night
i had a bunch of
ex-convicts
in their early 20s with the tattoos on
the face the teardrop and all that
grinding it out to make protein bars
because i gave them hope
because i showed them
that it doesn't matter who they are
today
it only matters who they're trying to
become
and the price that they're willing to
pay to get there
and so when you guys
walk out of here
that's what you've got to ask this whole
theme of pivoting this whole theme of
keeping your center
is about knowing what you
want
and believing you can make it a reality
but the only way to make it a reality is
to put in the work
you've got to put in the work the change
is hard the change is difficult the
change will demand everything of you
but man if inside you really believe in
what you're doing you really see how you
can get to that goal that you want if
you really see how you can serve other
people doing what you do with this skill
set that you've worked your ass off to
acquire
then you can actually make change in
people's lives and that's what motivates
me getting the skills has real world
implications it took me from scrounging
in my couch cushions to find enough
change to put gas in my car to building
a billion dollar business
it is absolutely limitless what you can
accomplish
now think about that if that's really
true if what i just said is true that
human potential is limitless
then how you spend your time becomes a
spiritual consideration
so when you guys part from here
one stay in touch with each other
because you're gonna need that
because if you're gonna start pushing
the limits if you're gonna show
how much somebody in your position can
influence other people's lives if you're
gonna show people the power of what you
do if you're going to show people the
depths to which you can touch another
human's life if you've seen the look on
somebody's face who has been transformed
by what you've done by them to see them
transform their vision of themselves and
to watch them before your eyes go from
believing that they can't do something
to realizing that they can that they
have untapped stores of potential now i
don't think that we're born blank slates
but we are so close to that
to worry about where your limits are
is to miss how much you can improve
so focus on how much you can improve
there's an amazing quote by alexander
solzhenitsyn the author of the goulet
archipelago
and what he said was
the line between good and evil runs
through every human heart
to me it's not about good and evil to me
it's about malleability that's a
statement of how shapeable we are now
here's the terrifying thing about how we
get shaped
it happens when you're young
you get all these things that come to
you that seem to be simply true
i believed
that the human mind couldn't change i
believed that it was fixed i believed
that my talent and intelligence were
just what they were
it all seemed true it wasn't like i knew
it to be a lie it wasn't even like i
knew that i had a choice to think of it
a different way and one of my favorite
quotes of all time is from albert
einstein and he said the most important
decision any human being has to make
is whether they live in a friendly or a
hostile universe
decision the most important decision
anyone has to make because neither of
those two states is empirically true but
either will immediately appear true once
you decide to believe it
so once you decide to believe yo
the world is working for me
this [ __ ] is happening for me it's not
happening to me i know this room has
heard that statement
once you believe that you start looking
for the ways in which that was powerful
how was the worst thing that ever
happened to me actually secretly the
best thing that's ever happened to me
and so suddenly i started saying how is
this shame of sitting in bed
how is this the best thing that's ever
happened to me
how is this solieri type awareness of
just how dumb i really am how is that
powerful and the thing that winds me up
when i say that when i talk about i
started from not being that bright
nobody thought i was gonna win my own
mother thought i was gonna fail my
father-in-law did not want me to marry
his daughter they think that i'm just
being humble or that even i
misidentified myself but the reality is
that's how shapeable a human being is
and i had made decisions i had chosen to
believe things i had chosen to value
myself for things i had built myself
around my self-esteem around things that
were not moving me forward
and so i began to change my belief
system i began to change the things that
i value
and think about values think about how
much they shape your life
depending on where you grow up
you could become
one of the members of the tribe on north
sentinel island who killed that
missionary who rolled up on their
beaches they just started hitting that
fool with spears and arrows and just
[ __ ] killed him
you could be that you could be a warrior
of sparta
you could be a nazi guard
depending on the time and the place you
grew up in you could be a manhattan
socialite you could be a party girl
you could be
one of any countless identities that we
see in the world
not because you were born to be that
thing
if we were born to be something then we
would still see some percentage of
spartan warriors being born today
we would see north sentinelese born in
omaha nebraska but we don't because each
of these places carries with it a value
system a belief system things that are
unique to that group that you grow up in
what your parents tell you about your
family about you what it means to be you
what you learn in schools what you see
in the media all of that stuff is
shaping how you view yourself and how
you view the world but it's happening
insidious insidiously because it is so
invisible people don't realize that they
are choices
now once you reframe all of this these
are things that i'm choosing to believe
and once you realize you can choose to
believe something new and thusly get a
different result everything changes
what is that mindset of constantly
working on yourself without judging
yourself to a deeper level without doing
it in a way that always pulling you down
but always pushing you up and you're
doing that in your relationship whenever
i watch relationship theory i think the
conversations you and lisa have
incredible so it seems like you're doing
in all areas of your life which era did
it start in which areas did it evolve to
let's just break that hole yeah so let's
answer that question so where did it
start and where did it go so the honest
answer is
that like many of the most amazing
things in my life they were born of
misery
and i was deeply and profoundly unhappy
dissatisfied with who i was what i was
capable of where i was in life all of it
i was just really unhappy about it now
the one good thing is i've always met
things like that with and what can i do
and i have a bias towards action
and then i've cultivated that bias
action which is how it's gotten extreme
and has permeated into every area of my
life okay so it starts with it's this
dark place this
like i said i failed in film school i
didn't fail in film school i graduated
second in my class but there was a
failure that was so emotionally
catastrophic
that everybody else would have been like
oh you got to be like what's the problem
sure i got to be in the class but i
didn't walk away with a
thesis film that i could use to get a
job as a filmmaker so for me it was like
whoa i just lost massively so i'm you
know in this very dark place i'm broke
as the day is long i can't afford
furniture i literally sit on the floor
in my unfurnished apartment like that
you know just it's a normal phase that
people go through but then put on top of
that that i'm feeling down and stuck
like i don't know where i'm gonna go
propensity towards action kicks in i
start reading i'm learning about the
brain figuring out how much of this can
i change i realize i can change it and
then that change felt so good and even
let's do a thought exercise this is for
people listening because you're already
there but for anybody listening and
you're listening to jay because you want
to get there you see something which by
the way you feel when you're with him it
is real and i love that about you
but like this sense of peace like the
normal slings and arrows of life he's
found a way to deal with i won't say
that he doesn't have them but he's found
a way to deal with it and that's what
you're looking for so
going into that it's like
if you
are in a dark place
and you hear
change is real change is possible
doesn't that lift your mood don't you
want that to be true
and once you allow it because you have
to allow it once you allow that to lift
your mood you're like i feel better just
by thinking i can change that was huge
for me that was like moment one was when
i realized i actually can change so this
thing that feels like a death threat
this like smothering cloud of just like
despair
it can clear away and it immediately and
it's not like oh it went from gray skies
to blue skies it wasn't that immediate
but it was it literally immediately a
lighter load just because i realized i
can change so i was like whoa i can
change
none of this is a death sentence that's
so like just amazing that was enough to
get me going and people are always
looking for how do i have that energy
i'm depressed i'm down on myself how do
i get the energy to push through
man you've got to find a way to find
energy in that you can change so
whatever position you're in right now
you can change no matter what it is no
matter how horrific no matter what
you've been through no matter what
you've done like there is a way out from
under it but part of it is allowing that
sense of lightness to be there so i
allowed it the important thing here to
note is that
everyone needs an ego everyone needs
self-esteem everyone needs to feel good
about themselves and the crazy thing
when you really stop and think about
suicide and this is a new obsession of
mine if you stop and think about suicide
what has happened
that person believes falsely
but they believe that they'll never be
happy again that they'll never feel good
about themselves again and that's why
it's referred to as a permanent solution
to a temporary problem
because that will pass
but in that moment it feels like it
couldn't ever go away
so we need to find things that make us
feel good about who we are because when
you lose a sense of feeling good about
who you are life truly feels hopeless so
that's critical and people often talk
about you know to stay away from an ego
to not pride yourself on things but i'm
telling you that person prides
themselves on not having an ego
and so it becomes what you pride
yourself on is absolutely incredible now
don't make the mistake that i made i
used to want to be smart when i talked
about being the king of remedial jobs
was because i wanted to put myself in
situations where i was the smartest
person in the room
and in doing that i was always going
into smaller and smaller rooms
but it felt so good to be right and the
problem was i was wrong a lot of the
times now when this one finally came to
a head my business partners who were far
smarter than i am in terms of iq
processing data
which i define iq as your ability to
process data rapidly they could process
data very rapidly
and we would get into arguments and i
would always lose it was very
frustrating and i remember one day
finally
i actually convinced them to do
something
my way and i realized
oh
i just won the argument but i know i'm
wrong
and so now what
i've gotten what i thought i wanted i
finally won this victory i'm if i don't
feel smart myself at least i'm getting
reflected back to me that i've i've
solved the problem
and now i feel
totally stuck
because if i really want to move towards
my goal of getting rich it does not help
to do things that i know are against the
company just to be right and in that
moment i realized what i had to do was
switch my self-esteem from being right
to pursuing the right answer faster than
anyone else and then putting energy
behind that and being like oh my gosh
timmy came up with the idea it was sally
and sally oh my gosh it's amazing and
giving them so much energy to try to see
it through because that's the right idea
and then i began to develop my
reputation of being the guy that even if
three seconds before that i had been
fighting for another idea once i
realized i was wrong
i would admit it
and it's amazing what reputation you can
build around that and it is way more
effective for business how do you think
about failure then
um not trying for me like to not have
the audacious goal to not really give it
a real shot and i know i'm constantly
gut-checking myself or am i playing at
building the next disney or am i
actually building the next disney that
means something to me so if i get to the
end of this and the world is clapping
for me and they're like oh my god you're
so amazing and look how far you went but
i know that i was only playing at trying
to get there and that i kept dialing it
back because i was getting too scared
that that would be failure for me the
first thing you need to do whenever
somebody wants something they know what
they want they've got a clear goal
they're prepared to do the work but they
just find there's pretty radical
inconsistencies as they're trying to
move along that path to really get
something going
number one is that you need to
really get amped up about why that goal
matters to you because once you know why
the goal matters that's going to be that
thing that gives you meaning and purpose
that turns into a passion that allows
you to show up and keep doing it when
you're bored because boredom kills more
dreams than failure i just promise you
you just get to the point where it's
such a grind and you've got to do it day
after day month after month year after
year it's just like it really drags on
it's like that old outcast song forever
forever
ever forever ever it's like it's easy to
do something once maybe you can do it
for a week but when you have to just
keep at the grind then you really have
to have a strong why so figuring out why
is it that you care enough about this
because by the way if you don't care
enough about it to do all this go find
something that you do care enough about
to go after because you can do anything
you want in life
just
not
everything
now if you're as angered by that notion
as i am you realize whatever it is
you're going to give yourself over to
and do all the way it needs to be
something that you are really on fire
about now getting on fire about
something you're not born with that you
cultivate that fire so you're going to
pick something starts as an interest
you're going to pick it engage with it
fan the flames of that fire by talking
about it to yourself to your friends to
your family to anybody who will listen
about why it matters to you and then you
go hard on that so like for me i'm
trying to build the next disney but why
why am i trying to build the next disney
because i've worked with so many people
in the inner cities that were
extraordinary far smarter than i am and
they're doing nothing with their life
why because they don't have the right
frame of reference their mindset
is so limited that even though they have
all of this natural skill that they
could build upon and turn into something
absolutely extraordinary they're not
doing it because they're not thinking
about themselves and the world in the
right way okay i'm not prepared to live
in that world right now in america the
number one predictor of your future
success is your zip code okay i want to
introduce you to a word maybe you know
what maybe don't called an animus
something that that pisses you off
enough that it animates you to take
action now you want to find something a
spark of something and really turn that
into this raging inferno of i am not
prepared to live in a world where that's
true and now i'm going to show up every
day and i'm going to fight make sure you
focus it
get it specific to a person don't let it
be abstract who's someone you know and
love that's struggling with that thing
that you want to put an end to do you
have a mom that's struggling with
depression a brother that has massive
anxiety whatever the case may be there's
something out there that animates you
that you want to fix
and you attach that to a person that you
love and care for why so that on a
friday at 2am when you're exhausted and
you're bored and you know you need to
show up and have the discipline to see
this through
you don't want to be thinking in the
abstract
you want to be thinking very concretely
about a person who is struggling with
that thing and then you can fight for
them i always said at quest i was trying
to end metabolic disease because my mom
and my sister were morbidly obese and i
didn't want them to die so a friday on a
2 a.m i wasn't showing up thinking about
protein bars i showed up thinking about
them and suddenly when you're fighting
for somebody like that and it's personal
you'll have the energy that you need to
see it through what does the meditation
uh process specifically look like dead
simple so i use a what i call just
breathe so it was born of mark divine's
box breathing at least he was the one
that introduced it to me
so he preaches do it four equal parts so
you've got the inhale is the exact same
length as the inhale hold exact same
length as the exhale exact same length
as the exhale hold now doing that made
me feel out of breath i just felt weird
so what i started doing was i'm going to
maximize the pleasure in each part of
the breath cycle so for me it happens to
be
a sort of medium inhale a very short
inhale hold a rapid exhale i just let
the air out and then a very prolonged
exhale hold and that rhythm feels
awesome and i do that for 10 or 15
minutes and i can get into an alpha wave
stay to feel calm creative um it just
feels awesome
that that's one of those things that
people that haven't tried meditation or
tried it but never got to the part where
it feels awesome
my heart breaks for them it is a tool i
rejected for so many years because it
felt um wussy to me and remember i'm the
guy that had to learn to toughen up so i
feared that that was like backwards
momentum and so finally when mark devine
looked at me and was basically like stop
being an idiot and try this and he's
like this tough ass navy seal yeah i
thought i'm gonna try and then it
changed my life i switched my
self-esteem from being right and being
smart to being the learner who was
always willing to admit that he was
wrong identify the right answer give
credit to the person who thought of it
and put more energy behind it than
anyone else
and that became my driver now what did i
do with that driver
i turned that change in attitude along
with my co-founders at quest nutrition
into building as vision said the second
fastest growing company in north america
valued at over a billion dollars every
financial dream i'd ever had in my life
come true
but at the end of the day the only thing
that mattered had nothing to do with the
money
and it had everything to do with we set
out to build a business around value
creation we set out to actively ask one
question what would we do and love every
day even if we were failing
and that for three very different
reasons ended up being attacking the
pandemic of the body
trying to help people live a more
beautiful life and there were times
where
putting that value first meant that we
did things that were less profitable
there were times where we put that value
first and it was outright stressful to
the company but that was the driver and
that was the thing that actually allowed
us to grow because people could feel
that this company was different they
could feel that we weren't after the
sale they could feel what we wanted was
to help
and in today's world
leading with that as you guys know if
you're at this conference
can have tremendous
rewards there's a part in fight club and
the gift that i would like to give the
world if i had which i did not but if i
had sat down and set my intention for
you know what do i want to convey this
is one of my like top five things that i
want to get across to people if you
really want to succeed yeah there's a
moment in fight club where he puts his
hand out and the guy puts a caustic
solution on the back of his hand
and it burns
and he tells him that he has to just
leave it there and he ends up holding
his hand down so that he can't take it
away at first because it hurts so badly
and then finally he releases and the guy
has the strength to leave his hand there
and let it just burn and what i'm saying
is you have a mechanism in your mind
called the psychological immune system
its job is getting to pull your hand
away to wash off the thing that burns
and hey you're fine again
what i'm saying is if you want to be
great
the burning sensation is you
having to accept that you've picked
something up that you're not as good as
you want to be that there are people
that are better than you that you're
not far as far along in the journey as
you want to be
and what you have to learn how to do if
you want to be great
you have to learn to let it burn
and even though your impulse is going to
be to turn away from that to not look at
it to soothe it by saying it's them it's
their fault they picked it up i grew and
grow up in the wrong place
it's fine for them they're wealthy like
whatever excuse you use to
try to let yourself off the hook for not
being where you want to be instead of
saying actually the power is the ability
to let it burn and one of my employees
was just asking me yesterday and he said
how do you not get overwhelmed and i
said you want to know the god's honest
truth
the second i feel that impulse
brendan i say to myself
you don't get overwhelmed i'm i'm not
gonna back down i will not break you
cannot break me yeah
that yeah get that out of your head
right now yeah and just interrupting
that thought with an aggressive impulse
of like yeah i'm gonna let it burn yeah
now i'm not a [ __ ] so i immediately go
hey
thank you psychology for letting me know
that oh there's a lot of things coming
at me right now yep so i'm gonna go
meditate but the way that i interrupt
the thought is by reminding myself not
to be weak who's in control right 100
they once gave me a list
like 750 000 keywords and i had to comb
through it in an excel spreadsheet and
say either yes or no
that took
days and days and days of mind numbing
yes no yes no yes no yes no what do you
mean 750 this was back in like so we had
um words that did we want to advertise
on do we want to advertise on these
keywords like so you would buy a list of
like powerful keywords on google and
this is all cpc stuff so do we want to
show up on these keywords yes or no like
here's our business you know what we're
doing what keywords would we want to
show up on and so i'd have to go and
clean the list there's no way no ai to
comb through it for us so
i would do that so anything like that
where i could i just add value add value
add value and everyone starts
gravitating towards the person who's
always upbeat great energy and never
says no and is always asking how they
can help it it is a formula that will
win for all time
and so that was it and i just threw that
that intensity at it because every day i
was like i'm here to get rich i'm here
to get rich and when i get rich i'm
going to go build my studio i'm going to
get rich rich rich rich and that was all
i thought about obsessed over it now
that would end up being my almost
downfall but that was my obsession in
your experience with all the you know
business experience that you've had the
books you've read the people that you've
spent time with what do you think is
uh
the biggest
impediment
to
people waking up out of this matrix-like
existence that's so easy for us to fall
prey to
so i've had a realization recently that
i'm not an all lanes driver there are
certain things i've spent so much time
thinking about that i'm very good at
answering questions and there are
certain things that i'm not so i'll give
you an answer that question from my very
um specific
lens which is all about the person so i
think that if the things in the world
that scare me
the divisiveness scares me and when i
think about what is the individual's
creation of that divisiveness it is one
a desire to belong to a group intensely
a fear of being ridiculed or emotionally
ostracized and
once we know that we have this like
sucking need to belong to be respected
to be liked you can really begin to
decide what are the things that you want
to be liked for respected for
and when those are things that you
respect yourself for then all of a
sudden it becomes very easy to do two
things to build something that is
born of connection community kindness
not that you're not self
selfish i'm very selfish it just so
happens that the more selfish i am the
more i like to connect and help other
people i am very much doing it for me
but it manifests in a way that is
humanity neutral worst case and i think
humanity plus ultimately so that that
starts with me having a growth mindset
so that you you want to see how you're
wrong that you can have these really
ferocious ideas but hold them loosely
because the moment that your identity is
wrapped up in your ideas you are in real
trouble man your identity should be
wrapped up in your outcome what outcome
do you want and are you actually getting
that outcome and then as long as you're
not a sociopath with an ugly outcome
like people that get into identity
politics and things like that
i'm gonna give them the benefit of the
doubt and say no for real the the world
they imagine is a beautiful world for
the people that they love and care about
okay fair enough so i'll just give them
that they're trying to do something
positive but when you look at the
outcome in terms of how it affects
everyone it starts to break down pretty
fast like
that's where it really starts to worry
me so that to me says that your identity
is based on something that isn't
necessarily
anti-fragile it's probably based on
something pretty fragile so to use
naseem teles term something that is
fragile that's easy to understand
something that is anti-fragile isn't
something that's strong or resilient
those are still defined by their
breaking point it's just that their
breaking point is far away but
ultimately even something that's strong
it's strong because you think wow it can
take a lot before it breaks something
that's anti-fragile on the other hand
actually grows stronger the more that
it's attacked so and that doesn't mean
you entrench in a position that clearly
everybody's saying like this is crazy
the only anti-fragile position that i
can think of is to be that of the
learner
that is truly anti-fragile so for
instance if you come at me and say that
i'm stupid be like amazing in what way
and the reason that i say amazing is
because i i know that skills make me
more powerful so you've just said that i
have a blind spot which means that i'm
less powerful than i could be and i'll
define power because i think it weird
some people out to me powerful just
means you can close your eyes imagine a
world a better world than the one that
we have today you can then open your
eyes and actually create that world so
that's the kind of power that i'm trying
to amass in my life the ability to
impact people at scale in a positive way
so
if you're telling me that i'm less
powerful than i could be amazing i want
to know in what way because once i'm
aware of it then i can address it
because i know about myself that i'm
willing to accept that i'm inadequate
because i know that it's a temporary
state i'm not good at it yet if i decide
that it really does match with my goals
and what i want to do i can get good at
it so it's not ego damaging for you to
tell me that i've you know i'm not doing
something in a way that i could be it
could be better cool tell me how when
people don't want to hear that it's like
oh it's they're in a very brittle place
they're being backed into a corner and
people lash out and they're backed into
a corner so at an individual level i
would say to everybody if you feel that
your blood boiling when somebody
challenges you if you feel like a caged
animal or like you're being backed into
a corner i promise you 100
it is not the truth of the world it is
that you have a fragile something a
fragile ego a fragile belief system
something in there can break and because
it can break you're trying to protect it
and the more you try to protect it the
more hardened and
potentially
violent vicious cruel whatever that you
may become so when it isn't
that and you're not afraid of that thing
breaking because you want to take
information in you want to assess it
doesn't mean you're going to agree you
may take that criticism and go i
actually don't think that's accurate but
i'm really grateful that you
gave me that piece of information and
look intention matters you can tell when
someone's just trying to be a so it's
like you've got to be
cognizant enough of that but when you
get to that point where you're you're
leading with
everything is my fault including the way
this person is coming at me i've done
something to make them want to come at
me too hard or whatever so
at the individual level i think that
that at the
fragility versus anti-fragility is is
where everyone should start you will
only ever get in your life what you
absolutely must have your absolute
obsession so you that says your
obsessions become your possessions that
is so true and so getting people to
understand that that level of like i
must have this
until it is that like whatever it is if
it's taking care of your wife if it's
doing something rad for your mom if it's
having a beach house whatever it is
until you need that like you need oxygen
you won't get it it is going to demand
so much of you you're going to fall so
many times there's going to be so many
obstacles and unless it must happen in
your life one of them will make you stop
like you said you can't be for sale like
if your will can be bought
it doesn't make you a bad person man it
really doesn't but if your will can be
bought you're just not going to get it
you don't get skills because it looks
good on the resume
you get skills because it lets you do
the thing you want to do
so let's uh let's use sports as an
example it's just all too easy not to
use it so
if you want you're in poverty and you're
um lionel messi and you realize actually
i think um who's the other one christian
cristiano ronaldo thank you he was in
the grips of poverty
and nice that's perfect so cristiano
ronaldo in the grips of poverty realizes
that playing soccer is a way out for him
and so he goes and gets the skills why
because if he can win on the soccer
field then he can actually elevate his
family out of poverty like when you see
that trail it goes back to the nietzsche
quote if you have a y you can survive
almost any how so
how am i going to get there the the
amount of work that cristiano ronaldo
has put in to become
one of the greatest if not the greatest
the greatest football player of all time
is it's inhuman anybody else would look
at and say nope not willing to do that
and fair enough but it was somebody who
said if i gain these skills
it will let me
dribble around people
score when other people can't score
galvanize a team around me leverage it
to be wanted by teams to turn into
financial resources to make me famous so
that i can get brand deals and things
like that all the things that he would
need to do to pull himself out of
poverty like this stuff isn't an
accident it's about skill acquisition so
there's another kid that had the same
dream i'm gonna use soccer to get me out
of poverty and did nothing about it
therefore did not have the skills
therefore could not elevate their family
out of poverty and looks at it like well
this is all circumstance it's not
circumstance it's cause and effect it's
how much energy do you put into actually
gaining the skills and did you gain them
or did you just put in the energy and
the effort thinking that should be
enough to gain it but you didn't
actually gain them so this is what it's
it's like the gift i want everybody to
receive is you can get good at anything
you set your mind to
but do you actually say your mind to it
do you have that inhuman level of follow
through do you keep pushing and fighting
long after it stopped being fun deep
into boredom because you have a why you
know why you're doing what you're doing
and you're just driving towards that and
when you have that you can accomplish
this extraordinary stuff but i really
think people now are doing it for the
gram you're doing it for the gram you
want to go to that thing and do it
because it's like oh this is going to
look good on my gram and look i've done
that a hundred times i get it but at the
core of my existence is not that at the
core of my existence is i'm going to in
the amount of time that i have i'm going
to be acquiring skills i've always said
that the most sinister thing about
excuses is that they're real like you
really do have reasons not to be
successful but now what like now what
now what are you gonna do like um i
remember i was giving a talk at google
and one of the guys happened to be
african-american and he said tom do you
think it's harder for me as a black
person in america to succeed and i said
that seems patently self-evident even
even just accepting that humans tend to
gravitate towards those that look like
them what i call the school of fish
phenomenon you always see the same kind
of fish with the same kind of fish so
being a minority just by definition is
going to make things harder
but now what like now you can take that
excuse and
give yourself an out to not try to not
get started which is something you talk
a lot about or you can say
regardless of that i'm going to do
whatever it takes to get where i want to
go if you haven't read angela
duckworth's book
on grit
i highly recommend it it is amazing i'll
give you some of the key takeaways
the biggest part about grit is sustained
effort over time
if you lose interest quickly in
something
once or twice no big deal it is what it
is you realize that it wasn't your thing
but if you
lose interest over and over and over and
over and over and you always only enjoy
the you know first six months of a
business and then you want to move on
you lose interest very quickly you need
to work on developing your grit being
able to sustain that over time because
building any business you're going to
encounter hard things you need to be
able to do those hard things focusing on
the hard things in fact i try to start
every day
with one of the hardest things to get it
out of the way to remind myself that i'm
willing to attack that all right you
want to be able to persist through
boredom and suffering i told you guys
that's one of my superpowers long after
everybody else gives up because i'm not
having fun anymore i'm still there
banging away at it that's really really
important in order to create momentum to
keep things moving and to finally get
them across the finish line a lot of
people are able to get something to the
50-yard line or maybe even the one-yard
line but they just can't quite push it
over the finish line and that is the
difference between somebody who's a
entrepreneur and somebody who ends up
being successful the way that they want
they can get it across the finish line
all right learn to tell the difference
between a lack of grit and genuine
disinterest if you're not interested in
something you need to move on quickly
but like i said if that becomes serial
you may have a problem
and if you're only good in the beginning
that's uh the sign elaborate we're
surrounded
they're in front of us
behind us to the left and right of us
[Music]
they can't get away this time
when you can be surrounded when you can
be in a position where you know
that you're outgunned
and still convince yourself that you're
going to win to go into it believing
you're going to win
then you'll understand one of the
fundamental truths of being a human
being to accomplish the extraordinary
first
first
you must believe
you have to believe in something even
before you have any earthly right to
believe in it you have to be able to
look inside of yourself and know that
you're going to show up to look inside
of yourself and see something that
nobody else can see to know that you are
playing to win to know that you
understand the way the mind works and
that if you can't believe it first if
you can't see a vision for yourself of
being capable of something
then you're not capable of it
and that if you want to do
what other people simply can't do
then you've got to start by convincing
yourself that you can do it
that comes down to a belief
about who you are
and what you're capable of
and that belief
is yours to hold
no one can give it to you
no one can take it away
is who you are
a decision
a choice
a belief
walk us through your goal-setting
process
okay so um normally it starts with
chasing my bliss so if you have read
joseph campbell he talks a lot about
this and this is really powerful and i
think that something people don't think
a lot about there is something in your
life and this is sort of my secret um
not secret because i've talked a lot
about it but it's like the thing i don't
think people are hearing me it's like in
you right now
i promise
is something that you love to do and
most people dismiss it and they dismiss
it probably because they don't know how
to monetize it they don't think it could
be a job they don't think it can be a
business their
family and friends have told them you
know that that's silly or stupid or
whatever
and so
they never realize like they're they
literally have a blinder to the fact
that there is something in their life
that's a raging interest it may not be
quite a passion but it's like a raging
interest
and so i'm always trying to start there
so the example that i always give to
people of a raging interest is video
games so a lot of people like to play
video games or they like to read or
whatever right so it's like the thing
that they go and do when they're sort of
you know
contracting into themselves they've had
a rough day or whatever or even jesus
food like people really retreat into
food right and so
um
imagine becoming a food blogger right
it's like food is that thing that gives
you comfort it's that thing that you
think you have this negative
relationship with you've got this really
um unstable thing where you eat you feel
guilty whatever like
if you could recognize that okay this is
something that i love there is a way to
find a healthy relationship with this
i'm going to do that and then i want to
talk about it and i'm going to you know
connect with other people
and even if in the beginning you don't
know how to make money at it like do it
because it will make you feel alive
right and there's that great quote and
again wow i'm really forgetting my
quotes today of who said it but it was
like don't worry about what you could be
great at do the thing that makes you
feel most alive because what the world
really needs is people who've come alive
and so like if you tap into that thing
that makes you feel alive like that to
me is the juice so turn inward don't
dismiss it no matter how silly or stupid
it might be like what is that thing that
makes you feel most alive so that's
always where i'm starting so when you
think about um what we're doing at quest
or now what we're doing with impact
theory those were both moments where i
turned inside and said okay what are
like what's me following my bliss like
this is the thing when i really
sit down and try to break down for
people what you need to do to be
successful there's certain places i stop
because there's nothing universal to
give them
and the plan is one of them right so i'm
i'm just
ridiculously psycho about people need a
goal a hyper specific goal and a plan so
my thing is identify the gap between
where you are and where you want to be
and that gap is a gap of skill set and
now you have to go and get those skills
but most people can't identify what
skills actually lie between where they
are and where they want to go they get
it like from the end result but they
don't know how to plan that out yeah and
i'm not like i don't even understand
other than just sort of by intuition how
i'm doing it i want to tell you a story
and the story is either going to make
you love me or hate me it has that
effect on people
the story goes like this my wife is
british
some of the story is true and some is
made up i'll try to delineate
my wife is british that really is true
let's say that she was in london
visiting her family
she's in the bedroom that she grew up in
the doors are locked the alarm is on
her mother is sitting quietly in the
next room
protecting her from all kinds of woes
and right at that moment a meteorite
comes screaming through the atmosphere
smashes through the roof and kills my
wife whose fault is that
now i know what most people are thinking
it's nobody's fault it's divine
providence it's luck it's fate it just
is what it is
that's not how i live my life
and i invite you all to adopt the
following belief system
it's all my fault
now i use the word fault because it jabs
people in the ribs it gets people's
attention it makes them angry
because they think i'm victim shaming or
blaming the victim and i'm not saying i
refuse to ever be a victim
and if i maintain control then there's
something that i can do about it now i
use that example because it seems so
absurd and yet at the same time i know
this is true
there is a group that track what are
called near-earth objects and they are
trying to make sure that if one is ever
on a collision course for earth that
we'd be able to do something about it
whether it's a laser or planted nuclear
explosion whatever the case may be now i
know they exist i even know where they
are
i've never called them to give them
encouraging words i've never sent them a
dime of my money i've never sent them
ideas i know they exist i do nothing
about it
so why on earth if it comes around and
that decision bites me in the ass and my
wife is killed by a meteorite would i
blame anyone else
i could have done something and i chose
not to now here's the great news i think
it's a wise choice i think the odds of
that happening in my wife are so slim
that it would be a total waste of time
but it shows you the lengths to which i
had to take my mentality
in order to learn the skills that i
needed to learn to get where i wanted to
go and the way that i define an
entrepreneur is somebody who encounters
an obstacle and gets really pissed
because the thought of giving up never
occurs to them and now they know they
have to go over under through it around
it whatever but they're not going to
slow down and they're not going to stop
how do you handle competing
simultaneous good ideas things have to
be done sequentially
and that yeah that's a a huge pain but
really focusing on one thing at a time
is super critical to getting things over
the finish line and this is something
that not enough people think about
getting something over the finish line
is is the key so
um
it gets really boring and there's just
an innate uh boredom to especially when
i um conceptualize it as being an
entrepreneur one of the things that
every now and then just sort of
tongue-in-cheek and for fun i'll
document is when we're doing something
really boring or stupid um like this
morning i should have filmed it lisa
spent like an hour wrangling cables
and it's like that [ __ ] is so dull but
it has to be done like otherwise
you you get right up to it like you've
got all these grand ideas you're gonna
change the world you're gonna do this
amazing stuff and then cables
are the thing that stop you right and so
that's one of the things that makes
amazon so amazing is they get it like on
a tactical level just from how do you
improve the customer experience blocking
and tackling blocking and tackling right
it's not sexy but you've got to do it
the blocking and tackling so it's the
same thing with doing things
sequentially you'll get these great
ideas you want to do them all and you
can do them all there's so much time in
life but you just can't do them all at
the same time so breaking them into
and if they stack and that like this
concept that tim ferriss has of the lead
domino like finding that what is the so
if you've got these five things that you
want to do
the order that you do them in can be
really critical and then i know that in
saying that i'm paralyzing people
because then they're like well i don't
know what the order is and yes that's
one of the things you have to get good
at is really identifying what is the
sequence in which things are optimally
done and the only way to do that is to
stop and think through it and think okay
what's the lead domino if i do this then
what are the other things that fall so
take um for me speed reading or the way
i do it audible that was like the lead
domino if i can train myself to
assimilate information faster then i can
get a skill faster and if i can get a
skill faster than i can execute faster
so i actually put a lot of early energy
into
learning to
listen to audible books at 3x right so
people always think that like i'm crazy
and part of me is always hoping like
someone will say show me your audible
right now i want to see that it's
actually at 3x
because it's like i put so much energy
and effort into like being able to do
that and people think that oh well you
just have some lucky skill it's not that
like anything you just push yourself to
do it and i'm absolutely horrific at
speed reading so if i hadn't um gotten
into audible i would have really really
had to force myself to do that because
it's the lead domino so find those
things that um
that are the lead dominoes and just ask
like what's gonna if i do this saying
what's the one that gives me the
exponential results on the other stuff
this has been one of my favorite weeks
and it's been one of my favorite weeks
for a reason that's probably very
counter-intuitive for everybody it's
because i've been tested last week i was
sick i don't know if it was the flu food
poisoning whatever it was but i had my
ass handed to me i was sleeping like 12
13 hours a night which for me is
absolutely unheard of and then this week
i had three episodes to prepare for we
shot them in less than 48 hours so
over the course of just a couple of days
i had to jam pack my brain full of three
incredible human beings mel robbins
jason silva and
wyclef jean it was insane and entailed
doing an absolute ton of work but this
is what i love this is where i get to
earn my reputation with myself i talk
about earning credibility with yourself
all the time and the only chance you get
to do that is when things get hard i'm
never impressed with myself how i act
when things are easy and i'm very
impressed with myself when things are
hard so i'm always actually looking for
those moments when things are difficult
when i know that i'm willing to put in a
level of work that other people just
aren't willing to put in that i'm
willing to spend hour after hour after
hour researching people having two
people on the same day that each require
a day or a day and a half of research
spending my entire weekend working on it
working on it literally until the minute
i go to bed i was listening to podcasts
and interviews as i'm brushing my teeth
literally making my wife put the dogs
away so that i could take every
possible second every transitional
moment everything to drink in a little
bit more knowledge and then synthesize
all of that stuff so that i could do an
interview that nobody else is going to
be able to do and that for me is what
everybody should be doing if you want to
do something great if you want to stand
out and i want this show to stand out if
you want to be able to pull that off
you've got to work harder than anybody
else
there's no substitute for that and that
is the thing that i love that is what i
love about hard work most people just
aren't willing to do it so if you want
to separate yourself from everybody else
get better
than everybody else and when you're
willing to put in that work when you
actually hunger
for moments like this where you get to
show yourself
because everybody else i don't care what
they think i want to know for myself who
i am and how hard i'm willing to work so
when you get these moments
take advantage of them when they come
when you have a hard road in front of
you
hit it with enthusiasm hit it with
excitement hit it knowing that on the
other side of that you get to feel a
certain way about yourself that other
people will never get to feel in their
lives because it's the way
that only people who push when no one's
watching
get to feel about themselves that's when
you really be extraordinary that's when
you really do something that's when you
will surpass
everyone around you because you just did
the work
you look forward to the test
you wanted
to be pushed
you wanted to see what you're made of
that's what it's about right now all i
want to do is go to bed and this is
where identity kicks in this is why i
have this painting here of michael
jordan from the infamous flu game
i got sick i don't know what it is
it's been the last couple days with
stomach cramps
fatigue fever
i've got a big talk tonight at usc and i
would love nothing more right now to
crawl into bed but i'm not going to do
that and i'm not going to do that
because my identity doesn't allow it
even right now as i think about the
amount of energy that i'm expending in
preparing for tonight and getting
through the day and making sure that
everybody here on the team is moving
forward is because of
that person that i'm trying to become
these are the things that i absolutely
have to do in order to keep pushing
forward to be
me it comes down to identity it comes
down to what
vision you have crafted for yourself
what demands you make of yourself and
how you react when you're tested at the
end of the day you should want to be
tested at the end of the day i'm
actually grateful that twice now i've
been confronted with either doing an
interview or having a talk where
i'm sick and the reason that i'm
grateful for that is i get to see how i
respond so what i will say to you guys
is
who are you trying to become
not who are you today but where are you
trying to get to and what is the price
that you're willing to pay to get there
and what are the things that you're
doing repeating in your own mind
surrounding yourself with that are
actually going to help make you that
person because at the end of the day
your identity is all that you have at
the end of the day your identity is
going to drive your behavior and at the
end of the day
there is nothing else growing up i
didn't show any early signs of promise a
little embarrassing to put these photos
up i wish these photos were atypical but
in reality that is what i look like
pretty much all the time
uh i always had some sort of clown hat
on i actually wore my pajamas out and
about on the streets that's san
francisco
um
yeah that was really where i started
wanting to do something with my life i
had this unending ease that i could do
more i could be more i just didn't know
how and i felt trapped but i didn't know
what i was trapped by and my own mother
who's always been my biggest cheerleader
who all but kicked me out of the house
when i was panicking and didn't want to
leave the state for college
i was actually the only person in my
graduating class to leave this state
wasn't something that people from tacoma
washington did you stayed you went to a
state school my mom still lives less
than three miles from the house that she
grew up in
so this is not a place where people go
off and explore but my mom always felt
like if i didn't do that that i would
have a lot of the same regrets that she
had that i wouldn't see the world that i
wouldn't discover myself and that one
day i would look back and say what if i
had only tried now what she didn't tell
me at the time but she has since
confessed is that she just assumed i was
going to fail
now my mom is hilarious she's not jewish
but you would think she is because her
whole life since kicking me out of the
nest she's been desperately trying to
claw me back
and so one day i finally asked i said
what is with that like literally you
forced me to leave and go to college so
why have you worked so hard to get me
back and that's when she said with
nothing but love in her heart
i just always thought you would fail
and that was a gift it was really a gift
because at that moment i realized that
the things that i've accomplished in my
life had nothing to do with being given
something at birth
now i felt this unease that i was
talking about that i could do more but i
was stuck and i didn't know what i was
trapped in in 1999 a movie came out
called the matrix that movie ended up
giving me the intellectual framework to
think about what was happening in my
life because there was something
limiting me there was something that
made me feel adrift
and this gave me the vernacular to think
about what it was and in the movie they
talk about taking the red pill the red
pill it's only promise
it's only promise
is the truth
that's it it's not saying that it's
going to make things better it's simply
going to reveal the way that the world
really is and that for me was incredibly
intoxicating and i took the red pill
intellectually and what i began to
realize
is that the mind
is the matrix in and of itself now
there's people that'll debate whether we
actually live inside the matrix whether
we're actually in a simulation and it's
a fun conversation but i honestly don't
care about the answer because i can tell
you right now today in this moment i
promise you
the matrix has you
if you guys know david foster wallace's
concept of this is water to a fish water
is so ubiquitous it ceases to exist
now we all have that same thing and it's
playing on us and it's keeping us from
becoming who we want to become
and that thing is our mindset it's our
belief system it is so ever-present it
is so ingrained into the fabric of who
you are in the way that you process data
you don't even notice it you don't even
know that it's real and this is the
thing that impacts your life it is your
inability to see that your mindset
controls everything that it is water in
and of itself now when i heard this from
shakespeare i realized that once you
become aware of the water you can change
everything
that you can go from a scared lost kid
in tacoma
to whomever you want to be
and in understanding that things began
to become possible what makes you happy
the the easy answer and the most
truthful answer is time with my wife the
other answer to what makes me happy
there's really two things so time with
my wife
and then the pursuit which i'll put in
all caps right so the pursuit of
whatever the pursuit of getting better
the pursuit of impacting the world the
pursuit of building something big that
that matters
the pursuit maybe i never get it i don't
care about that i care about the pursuit
i care about whether sincerely i'm
actually trying to make it happen not
yeah not just like empty dreams but like
for real i'm actually giving myself over
to this and i spent a lot of time in the
inner cities a big brother for this one
kid for eight and a half years
completely changed my life and then
having 400 employees and about a
thousand of which grew up hard
in the inner cities hard i mean most of
them grew up in compton i mean it was
just some of the most extraordinary
stories i've ever heard and
i realized that those people are as
extraordinary as anybody barack obama um
oprah winfrey um
tony robbins like they
all those same raw materials exist in
people in the inner cities that nobody
believes and nobody think will ever go
anywhere and they won't because they
don't believe in themselves and so we
were talking at our most honest like
what what are we really driven by and
i'm driven by that moment of awakening
which i had in my own life where i
finally realized wait i can learn new
things so just because i'm not good
today doesn't mean i can't be good
tomorrow and and that filled me with so
much excitement i want to see that in
other people and i want to see what the
world looks like when other people
realize wait a second that steve jobs
quote that the world is made by people
no smarter than you is actually true and
so if you're believing that these people
are smarter than you because you did bad
on your sats i'm just going to tell you
right now stop
so you can develop yourself so my
obsession became that humans are the
ultimate adaptation machine we are
literally wired from the ground up
in order to grow and improve under
stress and pressure so it's like what's
the phrase uh pressure can burst pipes
but it also creates diamonds so it's
like you need the pressure and yes it
can hurt but it can also make something
amazing if you're willing to put
yourself in that situation so it's a
weird twist of fate that humans um
in order to build the muscle you first
have to tear it right yeah so
but once you accept that that's how it
works you can do extraordinary things
when people say like i don't want to
intern or i want to make sure i'm
getting paid when i'm worth all that
stuff it's like
if you're focused in the beginning of
your career with monetizing your current
skill set you will never get where you
want to go because money only spends
once unless you're really good at
investing which most young people are
not whereas skills monetize again and
again and again and a great point that's
so powerful
yeah money only monetizes once or you
can only spend it once but your skills
can be monetized over and over and over
you talk a little bit about seeking
power
yeah and it confused me when i first
heard it i'm not sure i even liked how
you said it at first until i understood
it and so can you talk to everybody
about seeking power and what that means
yeah this is another one of those things
that
internally for me it's such a beautiful
concept
that i was so surprised the first time i
said it out loud and somebody was like
oh that's gross
and i was like okay i need to explain
this to you so to me power is the
ability to close your eyes imagine a
world a beautiful world the world that
you want to exist
open your eyes and then be able to
actually make that world come true and
so when i say i'm seeking power i'm
saying i'm seeking the skills that will
allow me to make the world a better
place it will whether that's to be able
to connect with people and build a team
and get other people excited whether
that's to be able to build a business
that generates enough funds to improve
the lives of the employees and the
people that we touch with great products
you know whatever that is like to
to be willing and excited by the thought
of going out and getting those skills
because those skills really are powerful
and to me it's like people misunderstand
power the way they misunderstand money
this is me 60 pounds ago
and i knew if i was going to accomplish
anything in my life i was gonna have to
get control of my mind
now ironically there's two ways to get
control of your mind way number one is
directly going to the mind which can be
very scary can be very daunting very
ethereal it's ephemeral it's hard to
grab onto it's hard to touch
but way number two is through the body
and so i decided that my kung fu
was going to be to get very good at
developing my body and in that process i
was going to learn about nutrition which
would allow me to help my mom and my
sister in that process i was going to
earn credibility with myself and earning
credibility with yourself is so
important
do it in microwaves for me just showing
up to the gym every day was a micro
victory i said i was going to do it and
i did it now you have to understand i
hate working out so for all of you crazy
people that get an endorphin rush from
running
i hate you all
running for me is like being stuffed
into a meat grinder there is absolutely
nothing pleasurable about it whatsoever
so whatever neurological thing you guys
get that you've been blessed with i have
not been blessed with that so for me
showing up in the gym sucks eating a
bowl of ice cream is awesome and so
getting
to
getting to a better place for me
was a totally different journey
thank you
and what that was was just showing up
every day and putting in the work it was
reading about human metabolism and
understanding how what i eat impacts my
body it was earning a little bit of
discipline every day knowing that well i
did it yesterday i can do it again today
it was not eating something that i
wanted to eat and most importantly and
if you're taking notes write this down
it was about changing my identity
because at the end of the day
identity and values drive behavior when
people come to me and they're struggling
with something or whatever
i always start with the same thing
there's one belief that matters and if
you're willing to take this on every
other domino falls from here and if you
don't believe this and we're in trouble
it's very similar which is that the
human animal is designed to learn and
grow meaning you can get better at
anything which is another way of saying
everything is figureoutable you can
learn this stuff so yes i get it you
don't know it now i agree you right now
today you're incapable yes you're in the
moment where the radio's broken you
haven't yet opened it you're not yet
trying to figure out like what pieces
need to go where you haven't done the
experimentation so i fully accept that
right now you're incapable but if you
believe that you can learn
then it all goes from there there there
really are only two macro level
motivators that we have in life and
that's pleasure and pain
and so what i want people to understand
is okay so if nature only gave you two
things to motivate you pleasure and pain
why would you eliminate half of them and
so most people think that life is about
avoiding the pain i'm here to tell you
right now in a very controlled fashion
it is about really experiencing the pain
learning from it so ray dalio the most
successful hedge fund manager of all
time has a perfect math equation pain
plus reflection equals progress
if you don't feel the pain you never
reflect on it so my thing is i spend 80
of my time focused on the beautiful
things in my life the things i'm
grateful for the beautiful things that i
want to bring into existence all of it
20 of the time though i'm in the
darkness man i'm in that tim grover
relentless i'm going to make this happen
if i have to break myself and i'm not
afraid to lean into that because i know
how powerful it is now if you really
want to put numbers how powerful this is
they did a study and they wanted to find
out what happens how can we get people
to endure more pain and the punchline is
hilarious so they would take people and
they would submerge their arm in a
bucket of ice and they would just
hold it there as long as you can now at
first it's just cold but after a while
it really starts to hurt and so people
would end up yanking their arms out
they found that people could hold their
arm in the bucket 35 longer if you let
them display anger
so put it in they get to that point
where they're about to pull it out and
you tell them
yell cuss do whatever you need and
they'd be able to do it they're the
expression of intensity even what i'm
doing right now i can feel myself ready
right i'm ready to strike my muscles are
tense i've got a different posture i
bring my chin down there's intensity in
my eyes like dude i'm now feeling that
because i'm embodying it right so it
makes me really feel that and so i
actually started to tell the story
earlier i hate the gym
but what i would do to make myself work
out is i would my wife would be on the
opposite side of the gym and i would
stare at her and i would imagine her
being attacked and i would imagine her
being attacked by people bigger than me
and that the only way that i could fight
them off is to get stronger there was
nothing beautiful in it i was not
worried about aesthetics i was worried
about saving my wife and by stepping
into that dark place and because people
were like what are you doing yeah
but dude that was i needed that
motivation to push past what i want to
push past pain boredom all of it and
just to really get into it and get a
result but i find that people shy away
from that look to me it's an 80 20 split
if you're spending more than 20 of your
time there it will be corrosive yes it
will start to erode your sense of self
because you're gonna feel badly right
because i would be saying to myself
you're weak come on like you've got to
get stronger if you spend 80 percent of
your time doing that that sucks yes i
don't want to live like that right but
not being able to dip into both you'll
just never hit the level of
extraordinary you may be fine you may
even be good yep but you're never going
to be great audacity is is nothing don't
don't worry about being audacious the
reason people fear being audacious is
they don't want to be me
ten years from now when this all fails
right they're thinking oh man what if
this doesn't work this guy's gonna look
like an [ __ ] and it's like yeah maybe
other people will think that i'm a total
dumb ass it doesn't matter and why
doesn't it matter because of technique
because if i know how to build a house i
can build a house so my thing is i'm not
trying to posture or be cool i'm telling
you i have a set of skills that set of
skills lets me do things i'm just
interested in doing those things so
whether or not i hit my timelines does
not matter i'm in the skill acquisition
game skills let you do things i'm in the
game of doing the things my skills allow
me to do so i want to impact people's
lives maybe i'm not able to pull it off
at a film level i'll find another way or
maybe it takes me a lot longer to pull
it off okay fine as long as i love what
i'm doing even when i'm failing
there's nothing to lose i used to post a
lot about what time i was waking up i'd
show myself in the gym sometimes at like
2 a.m
and so people started setting an alarm
and i'm like whoa whoa whoa like that's
not what this is like i sleep as much as
i need to i prioritize sleep so i
stopped doing that
because i didn't want people to lose
sight of what i'm really saying which is
that fulfillment is the punch line so if
we can just literally skip to the end of
like the whole thing that we're going to
talk about like all of life the success
that people are chasing they think they
want money and fame and all of that and
those things can be very valuable in a
way
but what i want people to hear in my
message about like working hard and
discipline and all of that
is the only reason that i put as much
time and energy into it is because i
love it so me
trying this method in something i don't
love i've lived that i know where that
ends and it ends with me quitting
um and you know that's something that
i'm sure we'll get into later but it was
like i did that the first six and a half
years of my journey as an entrepreneur
were about the typical grinded out stuff
and
look man it
it was an important phase of my life but
it ended up
really chipping away at my soul
and
i flirted with depression just enough in
my life to know how
dangerous it is and dangerous because it
will literally lead to somebody killing
themselves
or just dangerous in that yeah sure you
live a normal lifespan but you hate
every minute of it and so just really
understanding how you get out from under
that and
like lesson number one love what you do
you've said it before that when you
started out there was a time when it was
just about money one was just about
getting rich that's it i used to repeat
that over and over and over what i just
want to get rid of i just want to get
rich that's what this is i kept saying
to my wife i'm going to make you rich
i'm going to make you rich i'm going to
make you rich like it was
it was the core of my identity from the
time i was probably pre-teen because
this was tied to my desire to be a
filmmaker was film was i knew like
inside i identify as an artist far more
than i do as an entrepreneur and i was
looking at okay i love poetry and i love
filmmaking
well there's no money to be made in
poetry but i could become truly wealthy
in filmmaking so that for me was a
creative endeavor that i could also
generate tremendous wealth and so that
put me on a path which of course was
part of the reason that i went into
being an entrepreneur in the first place
was i needed to control the art i needed
to control the resources so i had to
like learn business and so going down
that path and really realizing what it
took to build a business and all of that
which is a whole universe unto itself
to have the will to push through all of
that difficulty it was i'm gonna get
rich i'm gonna get rich i'm gonna get
rich and then just realize that
maybe for scrooge mcduck who wants to
swim in his money that would be like a
self-sustaining motivation but somebody
even like a warren buffett
at the end of the day it money means
something to him and it's the thing that
it means that drives him it isn't the
money in and of itself and the problem
was i was literally chasing money in and
of itself if you want to believe in
yourself and have a sense of self-worth
you have to earn that and i wish it's
something that somebody can give you but
they can't but you can doing really
simple stuff you say you're going to do
something do it yes so my thing is i
said i'm going to go to the gym i'm
going to go to the gym whether i like it
or not i know that it has advantages in
terms of cognitive optimization in terms
of longevity all that so i'm going yep
um and and doing that every day and
pushing into the extra reps and showing
up for myself to get the result like i
feel good about that yeah and it's one
very simple thing that i can control
doesn't you know require anybody else no
one has to come through for me nothing
if you want to make a change you have to
change your vision of who you are
you have to begin telling yourself a
different narrative and the narrative
you tell yourself about yourself is
everything and if you tell yourself that
you're a scared undereducated kid from
tacoma whose family has never
accomplished anything let me tell you
what you will become
a scared under-educated kid from tacoma
who never accomplishes anything because
that's what you believe
you tell yourself that story enough and
it will become real
but on the flip side you could tell
yourself a story of you're a learner
you learn faster than most people you're
willing to put in more work than most
people you're willing to read more books
than most people you're willing to spend
an inhuman amount of time every day
improving your mind simply by getting
new ideas into the system and that you
will admit that you're wrong faster than
anybody else that you won't let your ego
get in the way and you tell yourself
that story over and over and over so
when somebody comes and tells you how
stupid you are that you're just a dumb
kid from tacoma you go you're right
that's amazing thank you for pointing
out that flaw because now that i'm aware
of it i can improve it because i'm the
learner
and once i switched my narrative to
being the learner it didn't matter where
i started it only mattered where i was
trying to go and as long as i had that
clarity then i could execute because i
believed i could do anything i set my
mind to without limitation when you look
at somebody with money especially when
you don't have it you admire them and so
you think if i had money i would admire
myself but it doesn't work like that so
once you get the money the thing you
thought would happen to yourself the
story about who you are you think it's
going to change and it doesn't
so that's when people become totally
disillusioned they think if i have the
ferrari i'll think differently about
myself if i have the house i'll think
differently about myself your
insecurities are coming with you
wherever you go so if you think anything
external is going to change that the
only thing that changes your
insecurities show up in the gym put in
the effort go to work do the things
suffer in service of somebody else do
something to bring beautiful things to
people that you love and care about do
something beautiful to bring something
to somebody you've never even met those
things will change your story if a
meteorite were to strike my wife and
kill her i wouldn't blame anybody but me
that is entirely my fault and i can back
that up because people like tom it's so
ridiculous how could a meteorite
striking your wife and killing or be
your fault that's dumb luck divine
providence like fate whatever you want
to call it but jesus man it's ridiculous
to blame yourself
and then i point out i'm on the board of
the x prize at the x prize there was a
prize presented that would allow us to
track near-earth objects better than we
are today i voted it down
there because i don't think it matters i
don't think that the likelihood is high
enough but it's there i know that
there's an organization right now that
already tracks near-earth objects i've
never sent them a dime of my money i've
never called them to encourage them i've
never sent them an email with ideas
nothing now i know all of this stuff
exists and i do nothing to stop it from
happening so
the only thing that i can say if my wife
were killed by a meteorite is i did
nothing to stop it i could have made a
different decision and got a different
outcome i need to focus on that to
remind myself i can always make a change
i can always do something different and
get a different outcome so if you come
in and you disrupt my industry my first
thought is not [ __ ] the world what are
you doing this is so terrible and
sinister we have to stop ai or whatever
my first reaction is how do i become
more adaptive
and
people are putting so much energy into
thinking like i'm frail i'm weak i have
to be protected that they become frail
and weak when in reality they are not my
favorite quote on the planet
is darwin is often misquoted as saying
it's the strongest of the species that
survive he did not say that what he
actually said was it's not the strongest
of the species that survive nor the most
intelligent but rather the most adaptive
to change
that's how humans became the apex
predator we are the most adaptive
species on the planet you can take us
anywhere and we will thrive and it is
that ability to adapt mentally and
physically that makes us amazing because
i'm a learner because that's my identity
and because i really believe whatever
skill set you have today it's already
taken you as far as it's going to take
you so
unless this is where you want to be for
the rest of your life you've got to be
open to change you've got to hunger for
it so a i don't fear change i actually
enjoy change because change has been the
thing that's allowed me to improve my
life consistently and so i'm always
looking for ways in which i'm wrong
because i don't value myself for being
right and once people understand that
that for me it wasn't in the beginning i
was just telling myself to do that it
wasn't at a limbic level now i've been
telling myself to value myself only for
my willingness to admit when i'm wrong
and to learn that at a limbic level it's
true so when somebody tells me i'm wrong
i have this rush of like oh my god this
is amazing because if they're right and
i really am wrong and they're making me
aware of this i'm gonna get more
powerful
so
and that goes back to my real belief and
skills having utility so it's like the
ego doesn't have utility yeah maybe some
but it's not when misplaced and built
around the wrong things can be super
dangerous but because my ego is actually
built around my willingness to stare at
my inadequacies when somebody tells me
that oh you're doing this bad wrong or
whatever i don't spend time it does
still sting i think that's just natural
so it'll be like oh that sucks but oh a
reminder that this is going to give me
something powerful and so i use it sort
of as mental jujitsu and then i open
myself up and i learn now i've got a
really special bonus clip that i think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
the science says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else that jumps to 95 percent chance
from 30 something percent to 95 chance
of you following through believe nation
we need to make this happen so question
of the day your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
here's one of my favorite things about
neuroscience this literally changed my
life this affected my marriage and when
i give people the answer jay they're
gonna think this is so dumb
but i'm talking to the six of you out
there right now who are actually gonna
do this
that are watching it it will change
their life dude you ready i'm ready
when you
take on a facial expression you will
feel the emotion
no matter what whether you want to or
not you will
and when i realized that the brain and
the body or any feedback loop
meaning that the brain gets as much
information so the vagus nerve i think
82 of the signals running on the vagus
nerve which is the biggest nerve in your
body 82 percent is your body speaking to
your brain not your brain telling your
body to do something your body telling
your brain what's up how to feel sending
signals that end up influencing massive
amounts of both conscious and
subconscious behavior
so it is truly a loop so i used to i
don't get angry easily and this actually
used to really wind my wife up
and
or i should say but when i did get angry
i would stay angry so it'd be like
nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing
nothing nothing boom now i'm pissed and
now i'm gonna be pissed for the next
eight hours or a day or two days or god
there were times i'd be mad for like
three days oh wow and i thought
it's funny i've never once
come out of one of those periods and
thought you know what i'm glad i was mad
that long that was a great use of a
saturday with my wife this is really
just a smart way of living every time i
came out and thought this was moronic i
don't know what you're doing you're
wasting your time so i had read this
study that said if you hold a pencil in
your mouth and then have somebody which
sort of forces you into almost a smile
and then have people rate their levels
of happiness they'll rate it higher and
i thought that can't be true and so the
study goes on to talk about getting
people to laugh out loud and all this
stuff and i thought okay i'm going to
try it so i would force myself to laugh
out loud and it would change my mood now
i felt stupid doing it for sure
and then but about like six seconds in
it's so dumb and so ridiculous and now
you're getting that feedback loop that
it actually becomes real and your mood
lightens
and so i wrote this letter to myself and
i gave it to my wife to read to me if
ever i was in a bad mood
and she only had to read it to me once
and it worked so profoundly that i
realized i don't need somebody to read
the letter because the notion of and the
letter was basically because whenever
you're in a fight with somebody and they
try to soothe you you reject that
because you think well they're just
doing that because they've done
something to wrong me i'm legitimate i
have a legitimate reason to be upset
they have an incentive a perverse
incentive to see me forgive it so i'm
not going to forgive it this is real and
some deep recess of your brain you feel
it needs to be punished
and so
in that mode you won't believe what they
say because they have motive so i had to
read this letter and it was like hey me
it's me you know i have no motive in
this i want nothing other than when
you're looking back on this for you to
feel like you made the right decision
and so what i want you to do right now
is laugh out loud that's it just take 10
seconds laugh out loud and at the end of
that you know it's going to change your
brain chemistry and i remember citing
the study and i was like you know it'll
work so just do it and so she read it to
me i laughed out loud it felt ridiculous
i didn't want to do it by the way i did
not want to laugh out loud but the code
that i live by is man you always do that
which moves you towards your goals i
want to have an amazing marriage so i
did it i laughed out loud and it changed
my mood on a dime and i was like i can't
believe this is real if you want some
incredible motivation with brendan
burchard check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there
you